Sorry, everybody.
Sorry, I forgot about the time.
The time fucking messed me up.
Oh, my God.
Oh, my gosh.
Sorry, everybody.
I had to do some work stuff.
And I looked at the clock.
I was like, oh, my God, it's fine.
I was like, I don't have anything set up.
down and i'm busy i was like okay i can get this done and
then i was like i'm like looking at time like oh wait it's
streaming time it's it's streaming did i finish the work the
thing is i'm never done with work i'm always working no but
today is like particularly uh stressful because like um I
might have I have received some concepts for my new uh for
my new skin suit and I was like working on like trying to
figure out if like if it looks okay like I was editing it
and stuff so I was like editing my new skin suit uh and I
was like with my tailor with my skin suit Taylor and I was
like editing it and editing it I was like oh that's will
this look good.
I was so stressed out I was so stressed out because I was
like oh my god I hope the dragon will like this sounds like
what if they don't like it?
What if my fucking taste sucks?
What if I'm fucking terrible at like what makes a good skin
suit?
like oh and I was like stressing it out and I was sending it
somebody I was like which one do you like the original skin
suit design or like uh or like what I did and then they said
the original's like what's the point and then I had like a
mini breakdown and I was like what's the point I wasted so
many hours editing this and trying to figure out what I want
and then people still like the original more what's the
point I was like having a mini breakdown And I was like,
what if I just have bad taste?
And I'm just like, oh my God, I just fucking be a tomato.
I don't care.
I used to, I was so stressed out.
Cause I was like, this skin suit is forever.
I can't just, I can't just take off the skin suit, but I'm
like, oh my God, This is technically going to be, like, my
new man look forever.
What if I hate it?
What if I hate it, but everybody else loves it?
What if everybody else hates what I think is looks cool?
What if I'm like, this looks so cool.
And everybody else would be like, this sucks.
I'm like, no.
So, like, so that's why I've been, like, going through the
past two, okay, the past, like, two weeks.
This is what I've been going through Like, but like, the
past two hours was me like Like fucking freaking out and
trying to figure out Like what looks good And I'm like, I
was like, this has to look good This has to look like me, my
personality Everything I like, my personality And like, it
still has to be unique, but not too complicated Because I
don't like it when it's too cluttered or too much It has to
be like easy to cosplay, but not too easy to cosplay Has to
look good on merch it has to tell a story and I'm like I
hate this I hate I hate trying to fucking figure this out
I was just like no
I guess I'm just it's been a mess It has to be recognizable
with a unique silhouette, but also not too unique because
you don't want it to be too messy and too cluttered.
But also you want to look nice.
You want it just to look nice and be like that's a nice
recognizable design.
And then I'm like, I hate this.
And I'm like editing it and stuff.
I was like, okay, this is like so many ideas I have to make
it look better.
better as a skin suit and everything and and then i sent it
to a friend and i was like what do you think which one one
or two one being the original two being my edit and they're
like one i'm like what's the point
i spend an hour and a half editing this what's the point
And like, if you think like that, then what if, what if the
dragoons don't like it either?
And so, so that's what, um, so yeah, I've, uh, I've, I had a
mini breakdown.
I'm, I'm, I'm, I've had a mini breakdown and I, I spent like
the last 15 minutes getting myself together.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
It's your skin, so you should focus on making it comfortable
for you.
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
But what about the branding?
It needs to have good branding.
So it's so painful.
I wish I can just like hire somebody to do that.
do this but then like oh my god it's so it's so painful but
like technically i did but it's just like oh there's so much
work it's so much i woke up stressed and then like not not
gonna lie streaming has actually been like my own my my only
place to escape like that's why i love streaming can escape
off stream life which is behind the scenes stuff i stream so
i don't have to worry about i like escape my behind the
scenes work and how much work it is and and everything and i
get to spend it with you guys too you guys you guys evalate
my stress for me so that's why i stream every time i get the
stream i'm like oh my god thank god i get to escape from
work i get to
escapism.
Anyway, today, sorry, I had to go through that little rant
today.
Little rant today because, holy fuck it.
I've been, like, really stressed out since waking up.
Rishi, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
The brand is Dokeybird.
There's no question about that.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, everybody, we are playing HoloCure!
Yeah!
I don't know if this game has a like when i opened it up um
like uh when i opened it up it gave me this it's like not
full screen and i i was like whoa it's so tiny
oh it does okay because i was wondering if we were we should
we should watch this intro
I love the artwork so pretty in this game.
I know like the music and I actually, okay, let's see.
Graphic settings, there we go.
Oh, there we go.
Can I, oh, there we go.
Flow screen.
Oh, you have flow screen.
I don't know the volume.
So, okay, let me turn it.
down a little maybe i don't know guys i hope the volume's
okay chat um but yeah i'm super excited to finally play hog
here it's been a game that i've been wanting to play for a
very very long time i heard it's like really addicting and
um the the biggest crime is that this game is free like this
game i know like um because this is like passion project so
i i know like why it's free uh and it's actually crazy that
this game is free because um i was reading the reviews and
uh and like a lot of people are like oh i don't really know
much about hololive but like this is a naturally really fun
game like i don't know like the the i don't know like the
story behind this or i don't know like how to like i don't
know the lore behind this but it's a really fun it's a
really fun game and the fact that the creator wouldn't even
was like refused to like accept donations or anything or be
paid for this is actually um like insane because like bro
you deserve money for making this game like holy shit uh i'm
getting rid of screen shake because i've always hated screen
shake uh but yeah how's the volume chat i'm worried it might
be too loud um uh my sound guy has been like uh some stuff
has came out for my sound guy so like i will have to rely on
you guys to help me with the volume control a bit loud okay
let me turn it down a little bit then uh let's see i'll it
down a little bit.
No, I'm thinking of the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Oh, wait, Sound Guy's here!
Okay, let's see.
Turning it down.
Sound Guy!
I hope everything's okay with you!
But yay!
Sound Guy's here!
Okay, let me see.
Turn it down, the music, a little bit more.
Okay, let's see.
Where is the music?
I love my favorite time.
My... Oh, wait.
I love... My favorite time is sound control.
Yippee!
Sound Guy!
Alright, turn down the music little bit um but yeah but i
understand though because like uh what i really admire is
the whole they said uh how i set up this whole like hollow
indie thing which is providing like funding and support to
uh indie developers which is um really admirable but i know
like the creator of holocure uh is not in there because they
wanted to like still keep up this passion project and stuff
so um which is understandable because the thing about
passion projects is that you have the control of your vision
and everything so like you know like corporate like you know
you don't have to answer to something higher up to you
regarding changes or things or like you want to edit some
things to fit more of what the people in the higher higher
ups would want for it so it's understandable why this kept
was free and also not part of the hollow indie um the hollow
indie wants to do is reflecting on what the fans want and
what he his vision is so that's like really understandable
and it's like really honorable the thing to do and um and
yeah you don't have to listen to like what like you know not
just like uh man what management wants but also like other
people um other people that are funding the company and
stuff like that so um it actually is like because like you
know what if like they want to remove something or if they
want to add something that might not be from the vision of
the original creator So that's why it's understandable why
this is still a passion project and the fact that they're
doing all of this due to their passion for this company and
the passion for like the individuals who are part of like
Hall of Live, like the talents and everything.
It is very, you know, like the passion of the fans is very
admirable and everything.
But yes, I've always wanted to play this game.
Everybody makes it look so fun.
I like watched a couple of streams of people playing this.
and it's very similar to a vampire survivors which is why I
was really interested in this because I've seen people play
vampire survivors whenever and then I've only played vampire
survivors once among us edition so that's why I wanted to
play this for a while now and it seems like an incredibly
addicting game and the fact that it still gets updates too
Alright, what's meta?
I just love you guys You're like, no, pick the character
That you enjoyed, pick the talent That you enjoy the most
No, as a gamer It is called Pick the character that's meta
It's all about winning
I need to know What is meta?
Right now, out of the five talents that are here, who is the
most meta to start out?
Right now is Mori.
Swing's in half circle arc in the front.
Stage mode.
Okay, defeat the last boss to complete.
Well, obviously, I haven't really unlocked anything yet.
So, I guess I'll do the stage mode.
Okay, it's like the beginning level of Vampire Survivors.
All right, go.
Okay, WAC, left click to toggle or right click to aim.
What, left click to toggle.
Oh, what can I aim here?
What do I aim?
Where does the aim part come from?
I guess if I have, like, a special ability?
Question mark?
Use a controller?
No!
Am I K4EVA!
All right, nice.
where where you aim your attack but i can just move around i
just move around for that all right give me that box your
main weapon can be adjusted oh okay but at the moment i
don't think i have anything all right 15 chance to negate
one hit uh uh when defeating a target you need to lock it
you can strafe while attacking right click game you can
strafe holy shit this is much more complicated than I
thought.
What the fuck?
Okay, increased damage.
Oh my god, I'm so confused.
Oh my god.
Who would have thought?
This game was much more confusing.
Much more complicated than I expected.
Oh my gosh, I remember when I watched Maureen's debut.
I like, I think I live tweeted it.
too.
I'm pretty
I'm pretty sure I live tweeted Mori's debut and she like,
uh, let's see when like Myth First came out.
Uh, we maxed out the Scythe, right?
Who?
Okay, guys.
I already took one damage because I was fucking around too
much.
It's okay.
I have experience.
I played Among Us Vampire Survivors.
It's fine.
Okay, apparently in the meta is to max up the scythe.
I gotta kill the deadbeats first.
It's okay, they enjoy it.
I mean, they're technically dead already, so is it really
killing them?
Alright, max up the scythe.
Boop.
Oh, this is not good.
This is not good.
This is definitely not good.
Oh, okay.
That was just a bait.
It's just bait.
I mean, since you're dead already, it doesn't really...
matter that we kill them again because technically they're
dead so they just come back to life oh do they have orbs
here too reduce the time between attacks wait four yeah
we're saving them oh you're right we're saving them by
killing them exactly uh one or three all healing is doubled
four okay four it's okay I let my chat tell me what to do
because I can't think for myself
This is for your own good Do not worry This is for your own
good Alright, 1 We're gonna max it out still Holy shit I'm
so fucking strong now
I think it's like The fact that like all this Like hololive
fans came together to make this Because it's a huge team too
That made this game Like that was nothing I got scammed like
the art the music the gameplay being more calm there's like
a home decorating thing there's fishing there's fucking
fishing wait is it three wait is this the max this is the
max right
oh my god that's a big guy that's a big shrimp oh no no no
no no No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Don't worry.
Thread the needle.
Okay, don't worry.
We can kill him.
Can't be that bad.
Wait, what is, is that the boss?
The mini boss where he gives you a chest?
I don't know what the hololive equivalent is.
Oh my god, he's so tanky.
He's so fucking tanky.
All right, we maxed out the scyth.
Her Cali headphones are a good choice because she has a
small dead spot in her scyth swing.
When you unlock specials, Callie can do big damage easily.
Thank you, Super Chat, Richie.
Thank you, thank you.
One?
Increase attack by two.
Okay, one.
All right.
I got this too.
Hollow's on.
What did I get?
What?
Oh, BL book.
Repel's target with orbiting BL books.
What is...
Black licorice?
Wait, BL stands for black licorice, right?
Right, guys?
What else would it stand for?
Yowie?
That's a Y.
That's not Yowie.
That starts with a Y.
One, two, three, or four.
Richie, thank you for the super...
Oh, yeah, I already read that.
Brother, thank you for the one gifted shit.
Thank you, thank you.
Who?
30% chance to life steal 2 HP if taking a hit while HP is
less than 15% chance.
Oh, God.
Okay, wait, wait, wait.
Just gotta get rid of these guys here.
Just keep going, right?
It's okay, I'm gaming.
Look at that.
I played Vampire Survivors.
It's okay.
I played Among Us Vampire Survivors.
I know what I'm doing.
It is pretty easy.
All right, for each target, defeated I'm gaming I already I
already know the strat okay turn down music one more notch
okay sound guy wants me to turn down music one more uh all
healing is double one for each target defeated increase
attack okay I'm gonna do attack we're gonna be like uh we're
gonna be like a glass cannon I can't die if I kill everybody
first what is these okay sound guy said the music It's just
a little bit too loud, so I turn it down a little bit.
But if it's now too quiet, let me know.
One or two.
Okay.
When do things get harder?
Oh, big taco!
Get over here.
Okay, I never told this to anyone, but now, I mean, I can
post it now, tweet it out now, but I actually have a...
Oh, wait, in a minute!
Wait, guys, no, that was a joke.
I don't want things to get a little bit harder, guys.
I'm happy with the current difficulty.
I don't need things to be a little bit harder.
But I actually...
Okay, wait.
Let me grab one, two, three, four.
When do you feel your target size swimming or death?
There's...
Oh, this is new!
Death!
Alright, two?
Okay.
own a uh oh my gosh wait there's i can't think okay two
again all right when defeating a target two okay two all
right now i get to open all right anyway there's too many
things on the screen it's so hard to talk i actually own oh
hey headphones super headphones 40% chance to hit and heal
10.
Oh, it's a super!
Okay, I'll take it.
Super is good.
I might not play gotcha, but I know super is good.
But I own a little a little taco.
A little taco figure on my on my desk.
That well, thank you for the thank you for the five gift
this ship.
Thank you.
I can actually show it on Twitter.
Let's see I think the artist I bought the artist I bought it
from I've owned it for like a year now And it was like the
artist I bought it from Was like Siru Siru They make like
really pretty statues Like 3D printed statues Targets women
100 TX take 10% extra damage When defeating a target 3
Three?
Throw an axe that's spiral is...
One?
Three?
Three.
Okay.
I'll do three.
Oh!
Okay, that's fine.
That's fine.
Everything's fine.
It's fine.
They died so fast.
Oh, they missed!
Nerds.
I imagine missing.
Alright, increased size of axe by 20.
Gain 1% crit buff every second.
um add one additional book multiply all damage dealt by uh
one two three two one one okay it's axe time but um i hope
the music isn't too quiet now and it's like at a reasonable
way i watched hollow fest okay give me a second let me every
time every time i wanted to talk having conversation Give me
a sec, guys.
We need to think again.
Sorry.
We need to think, guys.
Give me a sec.
There's so many things happening.
I can't have a conversation.
Sorry.
I just leveled up.
Oh, yeah.
I watched Hollow Fest.
It's actually like...
Oh, my God.
Fuck.
Okay.
i know how much work wearing those like 3d shit is so like
uh so the dancing and all that's the i am aware how much
fucking work all of that is so it's always very impressive
and like i'm very admire them for able to do all the fucking
flip holy fuck all the cartwheels and stuff Alright.
Oh my god.
It's always super fucking impressive.
Cause I like, it is a lot.
Cause like not only that, you have to do like dance classes.
Like there's like dance classes too, to be able to dance
like that.
And like obviously the choreo depends on like what they want
to do for choreo.
What the fuck?
Where's my sights?
Where am I doing?
Deadbolt, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Don't think.
Just jam.
All right, which one?
Three increases attack size.
Thank you.
This is Chatplay's holo cure.
Welcome to Chatplay's holo cure.
I'm the bot here that controls for you.
All right.
Here we go.
Oh, hey.
There's a gator.
Oh.
Okay, there you go.
We're fine.
We thread the needle.
Okay, I got a little bit distracted there, but we thread the
needle.
I'm full HP!
This is so fucking easy!
That's right.
That's why I put my name in here, Doki FPS.
Catch me at the leaderboards.
Doki FPS.
Oh, please!
Give me the box!
Let's see.
Reach, target.
Why do I even need to read this?
I can just let you guys read this for me.
Those headphones are saving you.
No, I'm saving.
I'm saving the world.
Three, two, one.
Okay, targets one take.
15%.
One for each target.
I see more threes.
Okay, I see more threes.
Open.
Open time.
Let's see.
All healing is doubled.
I'll take it.
I don't need a thing.
Oh, I got leveled up again.
Uber sheep.
Increased movement speed.
One.
Increases attack size.
One- I like how someone was like One, two, three, four.
Thank you.
Very helpful.
Okay.
Nope.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, it's fine.
It's fine.
We're okay.
We just luckily got help by defeating people.
We're fine.
Everything's fine.
I need to, like, grab some more.
Go.
Nope.
Get out.
Back out.
What's the lore, anyway?
Why are the fans?
I didn't.
and read the beginning pick a five back to thank you for the
akasupa thank you thank you um let's see one increase stamp
five two okay one i see more ones i i know like we all saw
the intro but what is the lore the fans went crazy and we
must save them because what's better than being um than
being dead.
Oh my god.
Don't worry, fans!
It's okay, because Mori's a grim reaper, so she can bring
them back to life.
Because she controls life and death.
Holocure cures the...
Oh my god, that's a big deadbeat.
Get over here.
That's not afraid of you.
Oh my god, he has a bat.
That's, why don't they just get a gun?
We need, we need a fan mascot who just holds a gun.
But I think that might get, you might actually get, like, I
don't think that's, like, good for merch, though.
Wait, they do get guns?
Wait a minute.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no.
Okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
We're, we're threading Danita.
We're threading Danita.
Wait, they do have guns?
All right.
Let's see.
Everyone is meta.
Okay.
Welcome to America.
One or three.
I'm gonna...
okay one i see more ones oh god oh i'm so fucked i am so
fucked up that that that map fucked me up i looked away for
one second oh my god that that area actually messed me up a
lot holy shit but okay i'm back to full hp i'm back to full
hp uh agent thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
we must cure them from being delusional with the good old
bonk stick
Um...
Let's see.
Three?
Three, okay.
That's alright.
Nothing bad happened.
Jesus Christ, chicken.
It's okay.
I'm back to full HP.
It's like...
Oh my god, why are the KFP so fucking weak?
Okay, uh...
Where's the box?
Where did I miss the box?
One, two...
One?
I'm sorry, KFP.
I'm sorry.
I'm just asking questions here I'm just I'm just asking the
questions of what I'm what's going on on my screen they
missed too Alright, oh, Nurses Horn, Psycho Axe, Workaholic,
that's me.
She's asking dangerous questions.
4.
Okay.
Oh my god, that's all of it?
I swear I had more.
I thought I had more arrows.
Or game 15.
Piki.
Oh, thank you for the 50.
Get the chance.
Thank you.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
Okay, see more twos.
Oh, and then we have more.
Oh my god.
I'm looking like crazy.
Am I doing well for my first run?
Or am I...
I can't tell.
I can't tell if I'm doing well for my first run.
Or if it's just like that.
Three or so far.
You're doing fine.
Decent?
Guys, come on.
Our first, you're right, our first run.
Let's see, one.
Alright, nice.
Holy shit, my axe is huge now.
I mean, it's the first stage.
Yeah, but like, but like, this is my first try.
Guys, as a...
Guys, as a streamer, I said that so you can give me an ego
boost, you know Yes guys, you know Whenever a streamer is
like Hey guys, am I doing well for my first try Your reply
would be like Oh my gosh, Doki, you're doing amazing
You're...
Wait, what?
Wait, okay I can dodge that It's like Toho You'll be like,
wow!
Doki, you're doing so good!
It's like you're a fucking gamer!
You're supposed to be like boosting my ego here.
Can I kill this thing?
I can't tell!
I don't know if she...
Yeah, yeah, I can.
They have a shield.
That means I can kill this thing.
Okay, nice.
Easy.
Okay.
Open.
Uh, oh hey, nice.
Nice, more black licorice.
Uh, it's a halfway boss.
We're halfway!
We don't like to lie.
What do you mean?
Four.
All right, more books.
More black licorice.
Man, I sure do love black licorice.
Because what else would BL stand for?
Uh, oh, we can max it out.
Okay, let's max this out.
Oh, go ahead and think about the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Your micro could be better.
Callie is carrying you.
Look.
I'm just playing meta.
There's nothing wrong.
We're playing meta.
Whoa, what's this?
What is this?
Combo.
What does this do?
Is this good?
Oh my god, I can't believe.
get black licorice what is black licorice um that i don't
know if you guys know what that means but it's like when a
when two black licorices love each other very much um you
you try to eat two at the same time that's what it means
chat that that's that's what it means um Thank you, thank
you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Don't know you notice, but items I have a star belong to
that specific talent.
So you can grab them, upgrade them, while worrying about
them taking up a weapon slot.
Oh, that's really interesting.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
One.
Oh, so this doesn't take my weapon slot because I'm Callie.
All right.
Thank you, guys.
Thank you for...
Oh, my God.
I can just stand still.
I don't even know where my weapon is anymore.
I can't wait.
You know, I can't wait for the real gameplay.
Fishing.
I am so excited.
I can't wait, chat.
The real gameplay.
Fishing.
I am the weapon.
The endless black licorice.
Oh my god, it's like I'm opening my own chocolate factory.
Fishing is hard.
How?
It's fishing.
It's like the best.
You can make fishing difficult.
it's fishing nightly milk increase attack size and knockback
effects of weapons by 20% also increases pickup range by 50%
all right we're halfway point 10 more minutes of oh okay oh
yeah oh my god here we go this is it i can't see anything i
can't see the enemies i can't get all this Oh my god, okay,
I made it It's actually so difficult I, I, where am I?
Where am I?
Holy shit, there's too many things swinging Reduce opacity,
wait I could do that?
Okay, reduce opacity Oh my, oh my god, thank god Thank you
guys, this is so much better I can actually see There's so
many quality Of life stuff that's really helpful Oh, okay,
threading the needle.
All right.
Honestly, I'm surprised.
I'm surprised that I did as well as I thought I did.
Wait, you can do that?
What a streamer.
Um.
Three.
Drop lava on the ground.
That's good.
Oh, thank God.
We're doing it.
Oh, there's a big clock.
Hello.
It's time to get...
It's time to get you out.
Get out of here.
There can't... There can only be one big clock.
Get out.
Down with the clock.
I'm always afraid of saying clock because I can slip up and
say the other.
big clock.
Nice clock, bro.
Nice clock.
Okay.
What do we get?
Ooh, a nurses horn.
Level two.
I guess we should take it.
Because we already have it.
What?
I'm just talking about clocks.
How is it you're going to tell the time?
The bigger the clock, the easier it is to tell the time.
They don't call me the big Ben for nothing.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
You missed my first Super.
Once you're back in the main menu, click the achievement
section.
It'll tell you how to unlock weapons and items.
Thank you.
Super chat.
I don't need to have the game tell me.
I have chat to tell me.
And it's like instant.
Who it means?
Who needs to have the video game tell me what to do When
we're doing chat plays holocure That's actually so nice that
you can decrease the opacity of the attacks Because like
That was like one of my biggest gripes with Wait can I do
more upgrade?
Oh What do we upgrade?
Imagine reading exactly We don't need to read Let's see The
site upgrade to size and oh i can upgrade oh yeah up size
i'll do the wait spider lava was too late wait cost okay
upgrade yay i got an achievement let's go yay oh my god they
have clothes now where are you doing it why do you have
clothes Oh, it's because of the song!
I understand that reference.
Oh, it's over here.
Okay, nice, we dodged it.
We'll give you clothes.
Okay, nice.
I was worried about, like, having a tree block me.
Q?
Oh, is that my alt?
I don't need to use the Q.
It's like... Oh, wait.
with the mv for some reason i thought you meant because like
overwatch ultimate is an apex ultimate is the q button so i
was like i have an alt but you're talking about the music
video q which makes a lot more sense now sorry i had gamer
brain on
i heard this game does have alt though so then i honestly
thought you wanted me to press Q.
I know this has alt, so I honestly thought you were like,
God, alt, alt.
There's so many people.
You should alt.
Uh, increase area.
I do have an alt, though.
Uh.
I have to buy alt?
Oh my god.
Capitalism.
You can't even escape capitalism and vtubers.
You never escape captives.
Can't believe it.
Pay the queue.
Pay my imaginary currency because the creator won't accept
anybody's money.
Alright.
Oh.
Okay.
Wait.
I'll just kill these trams first before I go for the box.
Oh, nice.
Oh, okay.
That's a little bit too many.
Fake capitalism!
That is worse than real capitalism.
Because it's a choice.
Oh, thank God.
I'm, like, fucked.
There's a lot of deadbeats and shrimps on me right now.
Uh, okay.
Nice.
We're fine.
Yay!
Whoa!
Sorry, we're back to full HP.
We have to head downstairs, though, because...
I need to, like, figure out a way to head down.
because there's the other box over there that I kept.
I need to get the other box.
There it is.
Yeah, I was trying to get the other box.
Okay, increased damage.
Alright, yeah, we got the circled around.
Daruka, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oinga, Korone max out her main weapon and get the trumpet
sticker.
Thank me later for...
Alright, thanks.
Oh hey, it's the saplings Wait, is that what they look like?
I thought they I thought they were just like seeds
Alright, and then there's the humans I think like When you
become a VTuber One of the hardest things Is to think of Oh
no, please Please, I was trying to have a conversation
Please, why every time why every time i want to have a
conversation okay okay anyway anyway as i was saying i think
one of the hardest things ever as a as a uh as a vtuber is
when you have to think of like good fan names and also like
fan designs to like the to have like a mascot representing
your fans that's like one of the most difficult things it's
because it's all about branding it's all i fucking hate
branding um three of increased damage i hate branding
because it's like you want to be like you want to be like
the next hello kitty yes oh god where where where oh god
okay oh my god there's way too many people Okay, here he
goes And there's like pillars too, please Please, I'm trying
to talk about Branding Please don't want it to be too
complicated Because you want the fan mascots to be Easy to
draw and like And but you also want it to be cute But you
don't want it to be too girly Because then Because you want
the fan mascots To appeal for both For both boys and girls
So it's like, oh my god No!
Leave me alone!
Okay What did he really...
It dropped three things.
Alright.
Alright, what do we...
What do we do?
Three?
The lava?
Is it lava time?
It's lava time.
Oh, and it's free!
Oh, God, please.
I have so many arrows.
Okay, here we go.
Please, let me have this.
Whatever this is.
Okay.
Cooking?
Alright, spider cooking.
Alright, nice.
We're fine.
We're alive.
The best thing about Hullocure is that, like, it'll always
be update, right?
Right, K?
It's...
This game will always be getting updates, right?
Right, K?
Because...
Because there's always gonna be new members coming in.
So that means they game will always have uh will always have
updates and i think that's really great because and the
backup is free too oh god oh god oh it's fine we're fine
this game is getting a little bit harder now this game is no
pressure or anything of course no credit card uh which one
three increase the frequency all right wait one minute left
wait really no i should have read endless this actually is
pretty addicting but i should i don't think i should do
endless when i um don't even have a fucking alt yet uh let's
see sean thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
fun fact back when this first launch kiara was pretty low
tier kiara then persuaded the dev and quickly updated her in
a patch now she's probably one of the easiest for beginners
thank you for the super chat That's interesting.
I mean, I guess because they're based off of, like, you
know, actual talents, they can just be like, why does my
character suck?
And then...
And then get...
And then be like...
Get, like, patched to become the beefiest fucking character
in the game.
It's just that easy.
But then there's, like, the whole morality of that.
Yeah, give me buff.
Make me the strongest character in the game.
It's okay.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
I mean...
If I have a character based off of me and I was an OP as
fuck during launch, of course I...
I prefer pressure the devs to do that too.
Do I just die?
I think I just die, right?
Oh no, this is way too many people.
Oh, the arrow.
Fuck, I forgot about the arrow.
Gamers don't look.
You have to tell me these things earlier.
Oh, shit.
Oh, that's a...
Oh, no.
Big Ami, please.
Please, let me get the arrow on the...
Oh, okay, okay.
She has a cooldown.
Big Ami has a cooldown.
Big Ami.
Oh, she's dead.
I killed Big Ami.
Okay, nice.
I had small knockback.
Oh, wait, no, I didn't.
No, I didn't kill her!
She's fucking...
She's gonna pound me.
Okay.
What do I get?
Uh, a four.
Okay, guys, we gotta run.
We gotta run.
Big army's coming.
It's fine.
Just keep running.
Oh, God.
We'll go right.
Why did I go right?
down okay we just have to like make sure that our main
attack is on her at all times so we don't have oh god i keep
accidentally clicking it i'm just reflexively clicking my
buttons when i don't need to it just locks the crosshair
wait why the fuck would i need controller mouse and keyboard
is like doable does controller actually make you a better
player in this game i don't understand Where?
Oh, there's the arrow!
Wait, we have to kill Big Am first.
Because she's closer.
And she has to be close to dying, right?
I'm following the arrow.
Guys, you have to yell at me if I don't follow the arrow.
Oh, God, that was scary.
I thought I died.
I...
Let's see.
Three?
Two?
Okay, three.
Wait, she's the end boss?
Oh, okay.
All right.
Before I kill her, I must loot Like a true gamer Oh, it's a
gold anvil Okay Oh god, alright How do we do this?
What is the best combo?
I'm also sort of getting locked in right now
Three?
And then Which one?
One plus two?
Wait, what?
Oh, what?
One and two?
But I can only do one.
Oh, not three?
How do I cancel?
Oh, one and two.
There you go.
Okay.
What does this make?
Collaboration.
Elite cooking may have unknown side effects if consumed.
What kind of unknown side effects?
All right, now we're good.
We should be good now.
We have like...
We have no more arrows.
It's just big army.
Yay!
let's see electric heart thank you for the super chat thank
you thank you kfp uses their own kfp as food do you really
think kiara would care about something like morehouse hey oh
shit i did it first try
yay i got so i got like 25 like not okay i got like like 10
achievements from main menu main menu and then i know i
heard you can gotcha for other characters now buy special
main menu right uh increased haste by 10 percent shoot a
powerful laser beam through the microphone blacksmith gear
credit card gorilla paw hollow house oh i got more stages oh
my god unlocked everything okay shop uh upgrades how do i
queue special attack oh this is the this is the alt, right?
Is this alt?
Femal.
Alt.
Buy.
Is there anything else I should buy?
Is there anything else?
Enchantments?
Here?
Alright.
And then stamp.
Stickers?
Which one's stickers?
Oh, is that stickers?
Drop by target we can modify the main okay is there anything
else I need or is it gotcha time is it a lot worth gains but
uh is it gotcha time or do I unlock anything else gotcha
alright what's armory oh it's just the information okay and
then this has the best character right this is full meta
right next thing thank you for the 50 gifted ships Thank
you, thank you.
Which is full meta.
It's all about the meta.
Okay.
Alright, we're gonna...
Oh, debut.
Alright.
Okay.
Oh, hey!
Hey!
Alright, you're not meta.
I'm sorry.
No!
I need meta!
No, cronies!
Why?
Are you serious?
I needed like one of these three and I get YouTube twice?
Oh my god, that's unfair.
I just wanted meta.
God, I'm so lucky.
I can't believe it.
I just wanted meta.
Alright.
Is Callie still meta?
You know what?
Ah, fuck it.
Let's go.
Alright, Bay.
You're gonna do meta.
We don't have meta, so.
Wait.
Recommended upgrades.
I don't need that.
I can do it.
Alright, Bay.
You might not be meta.
But we don't need it.
We're gonna.
We don't need it.
We don't need it, Bay.
You're not meta.
It's okay.
We're gonna be that Overwatch one trick.
That Tor drawing one trick.
Oh.
I do need it.
No, we don't.
We don't need it.
Bay is a glass cannon?
Perfect!
I love glass cannon builds.
Um, well, obviously I have nothing else to upgrade.
Wait, B is not his load tier?
B!
Tell the dead to buff you!
You have the power!
You have the power to tell the dead to give you a up okay um
uh fan thank you for the magenta super thank you thank you
fun fact about the gacha you can do multiple pulls in one go
before you pull there's an arrow indicating pull from one to
ten well based on by a thousand hollow coins thank you super
chat thank you thank you all right it's fine i'm clearly
very lucky right it's not like
This is it.
This is the day my luck turns around.
This will be the day.
Wait, what do you mean?
I just went for it.
I got...
No!
What do you mean?
I literally ran...
Oh my god.
What do you mean?
No.
I just looked at my chat.
I just activated hide mode.
Okay, now my luck starts turning around.
Now, this is when my luck starts turning around, chat.
This is the moment.
It might not have been like, it might not be like just now,
but this is the moment.
What does, I didn't read.
I didn't read the halloo.
What does hallo do?
I actually didn't read
Oh my god Increase his regular fad spawns more and fads
become gain one for every four targets defeated since taking
this What Increase regular fad spawns more and no I'm not
taking four I'm not taking out Okay, now I read it I read it
for real now I read it for real now Guys, it's okay This
time I've read it, chat This time We're not going to
Alright, two I'll just hard upgrade the dice And because
this is her Because this is her item Alright, it's fine
We're fine.
I'm just gonna go full-on on the dice.
Nothing can go wrong with that, right?
Oh my god, please.
Oh god, okay, it's fine.
I saved a burger up top.
It's okay.
Now I know to ignore every, like, hallowed item.
For reals now.
Oh god.
It's fine.
He's not gonna blow up.
Oh my god, this level.
This level.
Oh, no.
No.
Babe, please.
Alright.
We go full in on the dice.
Oh, no.
There must be another burger.
Where the fuck are the burgers?
Oh, there it is.
I knew I saved the burger.
Okay.
Nice.
Alright, we're good now.
Oh, gotcha.
Is that gotcha?
What is this?
Size, stamp, increase.
Okay.
yeah apply this stamp to the weapon apply it oh okay nice
finish all right there you go dive all right now oh i do
okay we're not going to use alt yet we have to like wait we
have to be patient guys we need to find another burger it's
okay we gotta wait we can wait we have to find another
burger okay we're slowly slowly we're slowly turning back
okay uh what is it two okay uh to use it and go okay one
increase critical oh critical hit chance is always good wait
is this a boss what do i do i do oh that's what i do we're
not doing for it
You can't trick me this time.
You cannot trick me this time.
I see ones.
Okay.
Oh, I got three!
I'll take all of that.
Throw an axe?
Fine.
Might as well.
Let's take everything.
I'm fine with that.
Alright.
What do we want?
Oh, baby.
A triple.
V for XP?
No!
I almost...
Sorry, I almost...
I actually almost clicked one.
I'm not clicking one.
That was close.
You guys almost got me there.
Oh my god.
Is that chicken?
Oh, thank god.
Is this one hit if the player does not get attacked by
target?
That target may become frozen.
I might as well.
Fuck it.
Just put everything.
Oh, I am not doing okay right now.
Bay.
Bay, why?
Oh, God.
It's okay.
She's in the head left.
It's like the library.
I just realized it's like the library level.
I need more burgers.
I really need more burgers.
Okay.
Fine.
We can't go through this.
No.
Oh, no.
Oh, that's not even a burger.
Okay.
please oh please have mercy what is the is he spawning more
oh no please okay we're gonna go left no babe please okay we
killed him rest in peace all alive
oh god where's my all
I can't there's so many things in front of me I'm on look
I'm literally on life support right now I am on life support
here I have like nothing oh god I live on I live on for just
a little bit oh my god I live on for like one second please
please Holy shit, that was so close.
I'm heading to the arrow.
I'm getting near as fast as I can.
Oh, nice.
Fuck it, I might as well.
There's nothing more for me.
No!
Be defeated while using Halu.
I went to Halu.
Alright, shop.
It's gotcha time.
I can do one gotcha.
This is it.
This is where my left turns around.
Okay, this is it.
Okay, um...
Alright.
Alright, this is it.
Do I have to upgrade anything or are we good?
Sana is good.
Wait, is she actually good?
Is she actually?
Is she meta?
Try to get Iris first for money meta to get to true meta
later.
Customer, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Alright, I believe in you.
This is it.
I believe in you, Sana.
Okay, we need to have the...
Alright.
How is her attack?
Okay, it's like a circle.
Alright, I need more.
more people to be around me.
I need more fans.
Alright, fans, get over here.
It's okay, I can't believe it.
I can't believe you guys took advantage of me not reading.
That's so fucked up.
A sweet thank you to the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
I overslept, but I'm here.
Hello, Doug.
Nice to see you.
I'm glad you were able to make it.
One.
Alright.
Nice.
Okay, we're just going to stay here because this is like
baby mode for now um guys it's not because cali was my my my
crutch it's not because cali was my crutch i am a gamer okay
it's just because i accidentally took halu or halu or it's
because if i didn't take halu if i didn't take halu we could
have made it we could have made it with bay i can i can
fucking beat any stage with any character
It's not because Callie was a crutch It was because I just
chose the wrong item My backseaters fucked me over
Let's see One One or two Stop the cat I don't know what
you're talking about I don't know what you're talking about,
guys.
It's only because I got fucked over by Halu.
That was it.
It's only because of that.
Right here.
Who would have thought you needed to read in this game?
I can't believe it foiled by my lack of reading.
Right here.
Alright, what else, guys?
No!
If it was a skill issue, there would be a journalist mode.
But there isn't.
Hmm?
There should be a journalist mode.
And journalist...
Oh, what?
What's that?
What the fuck was that?
Wait.
Oh, no.
I wonder what would journalist mode be.
Oh, God.
Please.
Please be a burger.
Please, I need a burger.
Oh, my God.
What was that?
Wait, what is my...
Does my ult just beig?
It's not...
Just stands still.
Alright.
It's big.
I'm just big.
Do I damage them?
By being big?
Oh, I do.
Oh, and I get to absorb!
Reduce the time.
Entry every 15 seconds.
Gain a 15 seconds.
Okay, now every time.
you guys tell me to get something i'm gonna read it uh
reduce the time okay that's her attack so i'm gonna reduce
is that like the is that the absorb like the how is it
called um that that like basically magnet right that's the
magnet right the thing that glows i've trust issues now oh
god oh my god this level is so difficult No, when they said
recommended, it was actually recommended.
I can't believe it.
The recommended upgrades was actually for real recommended.
Who would have thought?
That's crazy.
That shit was actually recommended for me.
Not me.
Oh, God.
I'm so fucked up right now.
Oh, no.
This level is so difficult.
Leave you alone.
Oh, no.
This is really bad.
This is...
This is so bad, there's a maze!
Goodbye, Sana.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I'm sorry, Sana.
But I gotcha.
This is it.
Meta.
Got...
Alright.
This is not a crutch.
This is not a crutch, guys.
It's not a crutch.
I swear.
I swear, chat.
I was just...
It's not a crutch!
It's just as intended.
Um, for this, you need these upgrades.
I'm going to ignore that because I can't read.
Look, I'm going to show you.
We don't need those upgrades.
when I show you with Mori.
We're going to be so fine.
I'm going to show you.
I'm going to prove you all wrong.
It's because I haven't mastered Bay and Sana yet.
I just haven't mastered them.
But you'll see.
You'll see.
When I beat this level on Callie.
Not because she is my crutch.
But because I'm that.
Skillful at video games.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, God.
Okay, don't worry.
We're fine.
Oh, more upgrades.
Nice.
Okay.
That's fine.
We're fine.
We're okay.
Good luck on the halfway boss.
I don't need luck.
I was...
Oh, okay.
It's fine.
All right.
We don't need luck.
We're just that good.
Okay.
We just got rid of an upgrade.
It's literally the only thing that haven't upgraded.
Don't worry.
I got a burger.
I ain't afraid.
Look at that.
See?
Look at all this money too.
Look at all this money that I got.
Look at that.
Alright, now I don't know what to do.
There's no scythe.
I don't know.
Now that there's no scythe, I don't know what to do anymore.
Poor?
Okay.
Nice.
This black licorice tab.
Okay, we can...
That'll be fine.
We KO'd him.
See?
Nothing to worry about.
Fucking easiest game of my life on Worry.
No, not the burger!
I'm wasting my burger!
I'm not afraid.
What do we do?
What do we do, guys?
I have an all...
I have an all two!
Yeah, okay, we're gonna need that for emergencies.
2.
Alright.
Nice.
Alright, let's just grab all of this real fast and then grab
this box too.
Grab the extra.
No, it's for alt.
I already have alt!
Guys, we're gaming.
We can do this.
I believe.
Nice.
Holy shit.
Okay, this is We don't need all.
We don't need all, chat.
We can live past this.
I guess we do the cooking.
What else do we need?
Customer, thank you.
The super chat.
Thank you.
Can't believe Callie's back problem.
Steps from Gary.
Okay.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It is a group effort.
What do you mean?
If I...
Okay.
If I die in this game...
It's your fault.
That means you're not very good backseaters Two three or
four Three or four Or one what okay
I had to double check that I read that right I was like wait
a minute is this what I think it is like I was like are you
fucking kidding me?
I?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Are you act like The one thing I got from the boss Is a
thing I don't, I can't fucking pick up Oh wait, is it
Norsehorn Really good?
Coward think of the I am thinking of the coins On the level
On the level where Oh god, oh god, okay There's nothing
there On the level where like I'm Dude, I'm not ready for
it.
Wait, what do I... What does that do?
Wait, what does my ult do?
I couldn't tell.
What did my ult do?
Oh!
Wait, what did it do?
A crit buff?
Oh!
Alright, what did we upgrade?
I wasted ult?
I didn't know what my ult does.
My backseer just didn't tell me in time.
Two?
Two.
Okay.
all right oh my god it does that's okay we needed this we
need more hp anyway we were like lacking in the oh if only i
was faster why why am i not faster oh no oh no uh i'm gonna
get life steals i'm gonna get life steal i really need the
life steal okay it's fine it's fine we're fine We don't need
to be fast.
We don't need to be fast!
It's fine.
We just need to find a burger.
I'm stuck here.
Oh, I'm not stuck here.
I am not stuck.
It's fine.
We'll see.
We're full HP now.
We're full HP.
Oh, no.
This is the boss.
The mini boss.
It's okay.
Alright.
What do we get?
Level 2 or level 1?
Look!
I saw somebody That's saying I was never gonna live past
four minutes.
Pay the fuck up.
It's four minute and five seconds
I did it.
I lasted five seconds longer I fucking did it.
This is an accomplishment Look I didn't say Which talent
that I was gonna get this?
Okay, let's see.
I feel like I need more life steal.
Just because how fucked up I am right now.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, please.
Please.
I need to grab more upgrades, but it's so hard.
Everybody is there.
Oh, my God.
Oh, okay.
We're fine.
No, no, no.
We don't need all.
We're not wasting it.
All right, what's this?
Energy drink.
Increased haste by 10%, but reduces max HP by... No.
Why are they all so bad?
Why?
I'm not taking it.
What do you mean?
It says max HP by 20%.
Take it?
Is it actually good?
I swear to God, if you guys Fuck me all over.
Take it for in the meta.
Okay, take it.
Which one?
One?
Three?
Four?
Really?
It is that.
Don't get hit.
I swear to God.
I swear.
I...
Oh my god, I'm so fast.
I'm so fast, you're right.
I always knew you guys were right.
I always knew you guys wouldn't fuck me over.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Okay, where is my...
Okay, we can...
We can kill...
We can kill him.
It's okay if you're fine.
It's gonna be fine.
We can kill him.
He's close.
Get over here.
Get the fuck over here.
Get him over here.
Get over here!
He's golden!
That does you...
That means...
Oh god, I think I had a heart attack.
That means you know he's good.
I was like...
I think I had a stroke there.
Nice.
We get money.
I have no idea if I picked the right one.
Oh god.
Okay, it's fine.
We're fine.
here see i told you guys i told you guys i could this is the
longest i survived he got when he got away i thought i
killed him rest in peace all right wait one okay how's i
supposed to know he just disappeared as if he's dead all
right wish one chat
Lose, run, immediately spend, run, loss, winning on gotcha,
lose, gotcha, copium, repeat.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
All right.
Nice.
And then, do we max out on a book?
Where do we get, do we get the, the sunglasses?
Three?
Three.
Okay.
Yeah, there has to be a lot because I dropped a lot.
I guess we can, we can, we can gain one more.
We can max out on that.
Nice.
We're doing great.
I believe in us.
I believe in our teamwork.
Chat.
Why are they so tanky?
Oh, they have shields.
Can I kill these?
Oh, no.
They just...
It's just time.
Oh, there's big boy.
Big boys here.
I think this is the best mascot design I've ever seen.
This has to be...
Oh, fuck.
Oh, it's okay.
That's okay.
We're fine.
Oh, we are so healthy.
We are so healthy.
Alright, nice.
No, we don't need all...
Okay, I'm a coward.
That's fine.
Alright.
I guess he's almost dead.
He has to be close to dying, right?
He has to be close to dying.
Nice.
I swear, if it's another Halu, I swear...
swear to fucking god it's three okay we gotta take the book
and the cooking do we take the fan beam or is it useless is
that useless or do we take or take it take all all right i
like how the one person that was like no okay all right
which one chat which one we need to get Two?
Okay, two.
Nice.
Oh, God.
That's a lot of bombs, though.
We're okay, though.
Oh, they blew up.
That's good.
They made...
Oh, shit.
Nope.
We need to grab some life steel.
Holy fuck.
Who the fuck was that?
The Onigiri's.
What even are you?
What's the fan name of the Onigiri?
I don't know much about, like, the JP mascots.
I don't know the names of all the...
JP mascots the mogul mogul the only the only okay oh okay
sorry i looked at chat i i'm sorry there's way too many
things going on oh no oh no oh how am i supposed to go
through the halls when there's so many of them oh god please
no okay it's fine fine We're fine.
We actually dodged that.
That's insane that I managed to dodge that.
Exactly.
This is why we have speed.
Look, I told you we didn't need that upgrade.
Chat.
Jesus Christ.
Why are you so tanky?
Oh no, now they're angry.
Oh no, what did I do?
Why are you angry?
What did I do?
We have...
Okay.
I can't go there.
We're gonna get more black licorice.
Oh god, please.
We need more black licorice.
Yeah I'm trying to get closer to the I'm trying to get
closer to the to the fucking boss There's just too many
things Okay here.
All right, gotta I gotta be able to kill the oh no get out
of here.
No Please just let me fucking kill him Oh, there's an arrow.
I'm I'm heading over!
Don't worry!
Oh, nice.
But first, let me grab this.
Please not hallow.
Yes, we got maxed food.
We got maxed food.
Okay, arrow time.
Arrow time.
Just woo!
Maxed book.
Arrow time.
What the fuck who's chopping down from here?
Oh, more cats.
More cats.
Please get me through here.
Where the fuck is the arrow?
It's above me?
Oh, it's above me.
What the fuck is that?
A crowbar?
Oh, knockback.
Nice.
Yes.
I always mean knockback.
Okay, now I'm... Now I don't know.
This is actually the worst...
Oh, how did I get out of that?
Okay, never mind.
I'm just gaming.
I'm just gaming because I'm naturally gifted.
Not because of the choice of the talent.
Okay, here we go.
It's not because of who I picked.
It's because I'm just naturally good at this game.
Knock, knock, back, help.
No, no, no.
All right, which one?
One, three, is she?
One, two, four?
I see a lot of...
uh i see a lot of twos or threes is three actually good
three or four okay we'll do i'll do three guys i don't know
what you're talking about oh my god what's coming oh okay
okay i always thought like that thing was gonna like come
down on me okay please it's like literally right there let
me grab that chicken apply this stamp to this weapon i don't
know what it does but i'll do it Okay.
Oh, I got wings, too!
Decreased damage of the weight.
Oh, wait.
No, right?
Yeah, I'm not gonna...
No, this has decreased the damage.
Wait, dead in 10 seconds?
Why?
So, what do you mean?
What do you mean?
What do you mean by...
What happens in 10 seconds?
What?
Wait, wait, wait, what happened?
What happens in 10 seconds?
One.
Oh, no.
Alright, it's gonna happen in three seconds.
It's okay.
Oh, it's oh, I got big!
Okay.
Oh, God.
I'm running as fast as I can.
I don't know what she does.
I don't.
Oh, it's a flamethrower.
It's a flamethrower.
I know what she does Wait, frozen.
I'm frozen.
Okay.
Oh, God.
Oh, God, please, please.
I'm so fast.
I'm so fucking fast It's okay if I go in a circle Big baby
big fucking baby is here.
All right.
It's okay the circle strike.
Oh all right i'm gaming i knew it the circle stride just
like real gaming the freeze clutch we're not doing i i i
could read hallo i can read all right okay what do we do two
two guys i can read
Alright.
Uh.
One.
No.
Two for collab.
Okay.
Two for the collab.
Nice.
What is this?
I swear to go.
Okay.
Axe.
Do I take it?
I don't think I have an axe.
I don't.
I have one empty slot.
I think the last empty slot.
Or do I sell it?
Max out.
No.
Take?
Alright.
We'll take it.
I think it's like good for collabs, right?
That's fucking right.
Dude, fuck that person that was like, you're not gonna
survive the halftime boss.
Told you.
Pure skill.
Okay, four, all right.
All right, now we have ten, we just have to live for ten
more minutes.
I feel like, I think we're set for life now.
We're set.
We're set for life.
We can do this.
Oh yeah, the axe with a...
The axe with a book.
With a black licorice.
Because I love having...
I love using...
I love to cut trees and eat black licorice at the same time.
Alright.
I guess we'll try...
We'll upgrade axe so we can collab later.
Axe time.
We have so many too.
Jesus Christ.
Who keeps giving you the shields?
They're expensive!
Oh my god, there's a collab!
Oh, there's an upgrade!
There's an anvil!
It's okay.
We're five.
We gotta grab the anvil, though.
Nice.
Axe.
Where's the axe?
There's no more axe.
Let's see.
One or two?
Two?
All right.
Two.
I guess we do the the plug, right?
What a fucking sentence.
Or two?
Alright.
Oh my god, okay.
Oh my gosh, there's so many.
Which one do we do here?
One makes more DPS.
Yes, we do the plug.
all right headphones or one or two increase weapon okay i'll
do i'll do there's more ones upgrade what do we upgrade i
don't even know which one to upgrade there's so many do we
upgrade our site even more
axe who axe okay i see more axes all right upgrade nice oh
what's bad once per second one Weapon hacks may heal a
random amount.
Wait!
Life steal!
Life steal is always good.
Right?
Yeah!
I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna get the life steal.
I know life steal is always...
What the fuck is this?
It adds one additional shot to range multi-shot weapons.
Does not affect melee weapon.
Wait, but I am a melee weapon.
I don't have to sell this.
Can I upgrade this for free?
Wait, can I upgrade this for free?
Can I strengthen?
Uh, upgrade...
Okay, upgrade, strengthen.
Confirm.
Holy shit.
I love not thinking for myself.
It's so nice.
This is why I'm a streamer now.
I'm pretty sure becoming a streamer has actually made me
more stupid because I have no free will anymore.
I...
As...
That is the risk you take.
Head empty, let chat decide everything for you.
Oh my gosh, she's from...
You like the movie Wally and then like the humans that are
on those chairs.
But like, and the robots take care of them, that's going to
be me.
It's like, what do I do, chat?
Oh, what do I...
Oh, hey, what's this?
Crit up.
Oh!
that's the dream right there i don't understand why they
would want to go back to earth
why would they need to go back to earth what's the point
replace swap crowbar okay swap oh swap with swap all right
here you go swap to Do we replace the crowbar or the
chicken?
The chicken saved my life!
Crowbar is good?
Okay, I'll swap then.
Alright.
Alright, here you go.
I swapped.
Alright, we're good.
And then we upgrade.
What do we upgrade?
Strengthen life steal?
Crit?
Crit or life steal?
Okay.
I'll strengthen life steal.
Alright, here we go.
We're good.
Wait, whose mascot is that?
Oh my god!
Collab!
Okay.
Axe and black licorice.
There you go.
Do we...
Uh...
That's the collab we want?
Eating black licorice while we cut down some trees?
Yeah?
Alright.
Nice.
Okay.
God, I love to cut trees.
Alright, here we go.
We're doing pretty well.
I mean, we're... This is like the furthest we've ever
gotten.
I haven't seen any, like, bosses in a while too.
Oh, God, where are they running from?
Who are you running from?
Oh!
Dodge.
Easy.
all right over here we go i feel like fan mascots they're
like it's like mini sanrio oh all right increase rate oh i
don't know any okay death or energy drink or glow stick are
any of these good death okay death all right i feel like fan
mascots they're like mini sanrio characters if you think
about it it's so smart it actually is because you have anime
girls and who the fuck are you who's the who's whose fan
mascot is that where the blue flames i think it's better
than death oh really i haven't seen i don't see that these
guys a lot often the comments yeah but it's like it's
basically like you get you get anime girls cute anime girls
and then you also get like Sanrio characters too oh it's not
official they're like unofficial designs uh do we get I
guess we can upgrade the tail who's coming out from here
because I don't see these guys often on social media I get
my news on Twitter
Doki is blonde likes deportation wonderbread man support No,
not Wonder Bread, man.
You know, I would not oppose to have the Wonder Bread guy be
like Oshieing me.
Because that guy, the amount of money he fucking spends
on...
And fucking Wonder Bread art?
It's like, it's a lot.
Bro!
He's, he's like an oily for sure.
True.
And like, if, if the risk is just, you know, talking about
Wonder Bread ever so often, like, I feel like that's like an
exchange I'm willing to make.
Like, it's just Wonder Bread.
Like, it's just, okay, increase.
I have, I already have that anyway.
He's a nerd.
Neurosurgeon?
I guess I'll upgrade the glasses Since I have the glasses
on, right?
He's a fucking neurosurgeon?
Okay, this is He has to be normal in real life So this is
his like outlet
Like I imagine like You know, since you're a neurosurgeon
You can't be like, like, you know A freak.
So like I swear a lot of like the people with like who are
like freaks on the internet with like the craziest fucking
like shit like they're like they put on the mask you know
like you know like online is where it stays like he needs an
outlet so that's why he's able to imagine your fucking
neurosurgeon is the wonderbread guy so for those who are
wondering what the guy so though okay do we get fan beam or
like the glasses do we like you're about to get like the
most like you're about to get like the most intense heart
search uh wait we're it's like it's like neurosurgeon has it
heart surgery sorry wrong area okay you're about to go into
surgery and and uh and like it's like some fucking 10%
survival rate or something and this is your like And then
your your doctor is the wonder bread guy like I don't know I
I mean if he's a really good doctor I feel like I shouldn't
care If he's really good at his job like it should be fine,
right?
As long as he's really good at his job
all right but anyway for those who are confused about like
what the fuck is the wonderbread guy okay this is like old
internet lore but he used to be like oh my god he could be a
better doctor now he could be like a better doctor because
it's like years now if you think about it it's been it's
been fucking years and he has to have improved his doctoring
so like anyway sorry i keep getting off track because i was
supposed to explain to people who don't know who don't know
who the wonderbread guy is so the wonderbread guy he
basically he okay wait uh i guess uh i'll increase that he
basically commissions people to draw like women buying
wonderbread and they're always blonde like he has this very
weird obsession with like And he just commissions women,
like, artwork of women, blonde women, drawing, like,
drawings.
And they're all just buying bread.
Oh, and deforestation.
Yeah, and cutting down trees.
And cutting down trees, because he hates trees, I guess.
And that's what gets him going.
That's, that's, that's, like, exactly what, like, makes him,
like, really happy.
in life um but like if he's good at his job i feel like okay
if he's like really good at his job like and it's like life
or death like i would like i don't mind if he operates on me
he should like have a card and be like you've just i was
saved by the wonderbread guy But anyway, anyway, um, anyway,
there's a lot of, like, there, I feel like a lot of them
are, like, really normal people outside of the internet.
And then when you find out, holy shit, when you find out,
like, when you find the mask that they take off, it's
actually crazy.
It's like those people that commission those, like, oh my
god, I used to be on DeviantArt, like, Because I was an
artist, so, like, you know, like, all...
There was only one place to go.
It was either Tumblr or DeviantArt or both.
Or other websites.
Or other websites for different categories.
But, like, this would always pop up in the trending on
DeviantArt.
And...
I follow him on Twitter, and from what I've seen, he's
actually very nice.
Locke, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
it's just it's just like what he's into it's just like he
has to be a really nice guy it's just that he's into some
really freaky um but like there was this like one thing that
kept like showing up on like deviant art like front page and
i was oh my god oh my god okay okay i was scared what that
couldn't tell like when i heard that that shit like freaks
me out oh my god i can't see
Anyway, do you guys know like this thing called what's
called bimbo mific bimbo mification Like where like people
would draw like apparently you I did someone wrote a new
wrote an actual like News article about it because it was
such a weird trend and
It was such a weird fad slash trend because wait what is
that what is that do I have to kill it before it explodes
Like, what does that mean?
Do I have to kill this before it explodes?
I'm in 18 seconds!
Oh, God.
Okay, I'm trying.
I'm trying.
I didn't realize I have to kill this before it explodes.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Holy shit.
Okay, as I was saying...
As I was saying...
Where was I?
Okay, so basically what that is was that apparently artists
made a shitload of money because like There was an article
written about it and they like talked about how much they
made like charged for like those types of Those types of
like art commissions and they made fucking a bank What this
is this it are these two the combinations What is that?
Oh dragon fire um and basically it is like oh my gosh Look
at that.
Like, it's like a nerdy girl turning into a bimbo.
It'll be like, first stage, she's reading a lot.
She has glasses on and is reading a library book.
Second stage, she starts reading easier books.
And then, like, she starts reading picture books.
And it's so fucking, it's so, it's so, Stop talking to me.
Okay.
And then...
Um...
And then she just...
She just...
Oh my god!
Is that Staph's on?
And then she just starts reading, like...
Like, I guess, like...
Dumber and dumber books?
Like, I can't...
It's so fucking weird.
Until she's like...
Until she stops reading.
No!
I swear I got perms for this game!
Sessa!
Oh, yeah, we gotta get rid of...
I swear!
We got perms!
Alright, here we go.
Until she becomes a...
Until she cannot think for herself, i.e.
me.
I mean, streaming is sort of like...
Bipolification!
Okay.
Um...
What do we do?
Two?
Four?
Increase love?
I'll do four.
That's fine.
I swear.
Apparently I accidentally wasted...
Accidentally wasted it for...
Oh no!
What is that?
Not Toho!
No!
We were so close!
I'm so bad at Toho!
My one weakness!
Toho!
Meta.
Please.
Ah!
That's meta!
Iris is meta, right?
What is this meta?
Okay, I heard, like, Moome's meta, too, right?
Oh, my God, I'll never get Moome.
I got meta!
Okay, nice.
We have meta now.
Alright.
Oh, I have, like, different outfits.
I want to be Santa.
Merry Christmas.
Everyone is meta.
Alright.
Okay, I feel like we can totally...
Like, how do I recommend it upgrades?
Okay, where do I shop?
How do I upgrade that?
Is it like...
Oh, stat upgrade!
There's another tab.
Hey, guys.
I don't know if you guys know this.
But there is another tab for stats.
I can't believe I haven't upgraded stats once.
I can't believe...
I can't believe it.
That was the one...
I was playing everything at by...
By default.
Whoa!
No wonder everybody was like, Doki Stats!
Guys, I didn't realize.
I didn't realize there was a whole nother tab.
That's fucking crazy.
Guys, there was a whole nother tab.
Did you guys know that?
Oh my god.
You know what?
Maybe I do baby.
Yeah.
Um.
Justice!
Thank you for the Aka Aka Supa!
Thank you!
Hey, is it too late to see you play Phasmophobia?
Thank you for the Aka Aka Aka Supa.
And maybe one day.
Is Phasmophobia even so popular?
Okay.
What do we get?
These are all new stuff.
money is 200.4?
Alright, 4.
This.
I can't believe it.
There was a whole new other level.
I can't.
Who?
I told you!
Streaming is like modern day film.
It's modern day.
Sam, thank you for the 50 gifted ships.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you!
Really appreciate it!
Thank you so much!
Uh, alright, we'll do.
Do we stop?
Ah!
I read chat!
Alright, that's fine.
We're fine.
I just gotta kill some deadbeats real fast and the shrimps.
Boop!
Nice.
Uh, I guess we upgrade fully on...
Uh, fully on her weapon, right?
there's a pity section for the gotcha by the way 10 pulls
equals one redeem of character oh i love pity this is
exactly why i don't do gotcha i try to avoid gotcha game is
because i'm worried i'm actually gonna find a gotcha game
that i'm really gonna like i like i'm so scared that like
eventually even though like i try not to be invested in i
don't do gotcha game it's because my one fear is that i'll
actually get invested in gotcha games and then i'm gonna
lose all my money that is my one fear because like gotcha is
it's like there's two things that can like be scary um being
invested in gotcha games or being invested in gambling that
is like the word the the worst fears to have because you
know your wallet is not going to like it your wallet is not
going to like thing of a gotcha is like the game will
eventually shut down one day and then like okay hope
increase quit hit because like the game is going to
eventually one day be shut down with all the servers and
stuff so then you have to think like oh my god all that
money my pngs and then because i already am in fortnite
skins and like i personally have already spent like at least
a thousand dollars on fortnite skins and like that scares me
you know what fuck it we'll get more enemies like this
should be fine there's more money right this is iris is like
the my wives and husbandos um okay we're getting hollow now
because like we're we can take it you know what fuck it i
ain't scared i have meta!
Amazing.
It is a lot.
Wait, what does... What is my hope?
Oh, it's a bomb.
Okay.
That's a bomb.
Alright, let's see.
Grab like her or...
Oh, nice.
That's good.
What is this?
Uh, I guess I'll upgrade.
I'm not gonna upgrade Halu.
It's the greed time!
Okay, never... No, that's fine.
I don't need more greed.
All right.
Other than three.
What else?
Who?
Okay.
Guys, we need to max out our shit before we get more greedy.
Guys.
We need to be stronger before we can get greedy.
Okay.
Wait, what's that?
Oh, it's just deadbeats.
It's just a few of them.
But yeah, that's what I'm afraid of.
of.
I'm afraid of like actually getting really invested in
gotcha and that and then like, because I already have a
Fortnite issue and then I have to think about having a
gotcha issue.
Fuck, I didn't read what she does so I hope it's not
anything that would fuck me over.
It is dangerous when you have like your main gotcha game.
It's so dangerous.
Okay.
It's so, oh my god No, I can't That's NDA asking
I was gonna say Okay, I was like curious Cause I was like I
was like, cause you know like Okay, I'm not getting three I
was like thinking about like You know like, oh my god Like
those like casino sponsors Oh my, they get paid So much
money Like it's actually crazy but obviously I can't say
what how
it's actually crazy oh okay we it'll be fine we'll be fine
we'll find a burger we'll find a burger we'll be fine
no no of course I'm of course I didn't curious because I was
like I was like how much do they get paid for that and I'm
like oh my which makes sense because like if you own a
casino you have to make so much money because like because
like it's Las Vegas my attacks will look pretty there's no
nice that's all I want as long as it looks pretty the best
upgrade there is Because, like, like, Las Vegas rent in
general has to be fucking insane.
Because, like, you know, like, the spear?
I talked about this before.
But, like, uh, I guess we do half-angel or the RGB meta.
Or one?
Okay, one.
Okay, so, like, oh, God.
My hands were off my keyboard.
Because, like, the sphere in las vegas you know like i
forgot like for like 30 seconds of advertising on the sphere
is like what like like 20 000 it has to be more is it more i
don't remember it's more right it's not profit okay they're
not they're making zero profit by the way off of the sphere
it cost a lot it was more than 30 000 i remember i ranted
about it It's not 30,000.
It was like 100.
Is it 100,000 or some shit for like 30 seconds?
It's like so much.
By the way, the sphere right now makes zero profit.
It would take them like, I think like 10 to 20 years before
they actually see real profit.
Yeah, 450k per day.
Yeah, if you want to be on the sphere, you have to pay
450,000 a day to be on the sphere.
sphere oh god bomb time but it's so cool though that is true
but it's also 450 000
yeah like okay here's to give context so oh chicken okay
here's to give context um um to have like an advertisement
on the uh on the the tokyo Oh, God, please, please.
The Tokyo, like, subways?
Oh, no.
What do we get?
All right.
Oh, what did I get?
I did.
Where did I get to?
You get an upgrade.
Okay.
I don't know what upgrade I got, chat.
I don't know.
I stop.
Okay.
I'm focused.
Doki on the sphere fun.
Rico, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I don't know what I got.
Oh shit.
Oh my god.
It's super chat time.
Guys!
Oh my god!
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you!
Alright, what do we got here?
Pay up.
Super chat.
Yeah, baby.
Oh my god!
Blue Supers!
and green soupas Clore Okay, what was I saying?
Okay, to give context.
Oh my, okay, guys, give me a second.
I need to, like, clear this up first.
I mean, yes.
Sanders, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Okay, where was that?
Wait, who's Sanders?
Did I just made him a name?
Oh, no, there you go.
I was like, I was like, I actually read the note.
There you are.
Sanders.
Gatsun, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Renard, thank you for the super chat.
You know, I'm confident.
I'm so fucking confident now.
Okay.
Oh my god, level two super chats.
Level three.
What's a level three super chat?
What does all?
Oh my god, what does a level three super chat look like?
Increased lava of mine.
Does someone say super chat Super Chat, thank you.
Thank you, Shock.
Okay.
Wait.
Speed up.
Lava.
Band-Aid.
Everyone can hit your 10s.
HP out of your 3 seconds until 80% of...
Alright, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Super Chat time.
Alright.
Let's see.
3 or 4.
Oh my god, Luch.
Thank you for that.
Aka Supa!
Thank you.
Super chat.
Alright, 3.
What is this?
The first target, this weapon hit is marked.
The marked target was he...
Oh, nice.
Wait, that's good.
That's great.
Free super chats.
Yes, when you get to level 4 super chat time, all super
chats become free.
That is my goal.
We need to hit level 4 super chats so it can be free.
And then we can bankrupt YouTube.
It's like Amazon Prime.
your favorite twitch streamer for free um for throw two lava
buckets super channel time david thank you for the akasupa
thank you thank you three or two i guess i'll do i'll do two
then nice level three every every time i look away okay i
need oh my god wait he's cold wait he's cold why are he cold
We're at level three right now.
We're almost there.
Okay.
Okay, we're going to grab this.
Increase crit.
I guess we'll do hope level three, right?
Oh, he's marked.
Oh, that's why.
I'm stupid, Chad.
I'm stupid.
The goal is to have Doki, let Doki.
Oh, my God, we're at level four!
Guys, all super chats are down for me.
Asterisk Legally Legal-wise, all super chats are not free
right now That is a joke If you accidentally try to super
chat me all your money And your bank calls me You cannot use
the excuse that Oh, I was watching a jokie bird stream And
she told me that level 4 super chats are now free So I'm
exempt from No Is legally speaking it is a joke But level 4
super chats super chats let's go oh hey what's this attacks
have attempted to cause an explosion that has nearby targets
for 30 percent of the weapons oh wait that's good that's
that's good i was like what is what is before i want all
right oh oh this is not good this is not getting good i'm
gonna run through i'm just gonna run through i'm trying to
get to the air I think I took too many hollows Guys, I think
I took too many hollows Oh my god, it's totally free
Alright, attacks have 3% chance to hit Wall of Coins Oh,
okay, I'm sorry, we don't need RGBs anymore
I'm sorry, RGB Oh, I should sell it Wait, I forgot, I can
sell this Oh, I can strengthen this Wait, where do we Free,
say, God Go ahead, thank you for this super chat thank you
thank you look i gotta freeze look at that it's working
other people are getting free super chats too guys it's
working it was a joke guys just so you guys remember this is
a joke okay well dude indeed fuck it too late already spent
all my savings thank you for the super chat Thank you.
Is there, is it possible to go beyond?
Dad, thank you for the Aka Supa!
Thank you, thank you.
Did someone say free Supas?
Thank you for the Aka Supa.
Thank you.
Is there a level five?
Can we go even further?
What the fuck would a level five Supa be?
You just give me your credit card.
Level five.
beyond there is a level five oh my god level five you call
your bank and then transfer your bank ownership bank account
ownership that is level five oh my god guys
oh my god it's here oh my god level five eat the rich all
right let's get that lava oh my god i can't believe it oh my
god think of all the interest rates we're gonna get together
there's a level five as a blank check
level five you start a trust fund on your dokey's name
It's...
Holy shit.
I'm still alive!
Free Supas, let's go!
Thank you for the magenta super.
Thank you, thank you.
It's okay.
I'm okay, guys.
Look at that.
I'm gaming.
Iris is truly meta.
Oh my god.
Irish, I knew...
I knew Santa would not let me down.
I knew it.
I knew Santa would never let me down!
Get over here.
Get over.
Oh, my God.
Oh, wait.
What did I get?
Oh, haste.
Reduce the time.
Wait.
The first.
What do I get rid of?
Do I get rid of or do I upgrade?
Should I just use this to upgrade?
Do I just use this to upgrade, guys?
Doki, where is my wallet?
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the 50 gift and shows.
Okay.
We'll beef that up.
Jesus.
We are so strong right now.
Uh, okay.
Now I don't know what to upgrade.
They're all new.
Uh.
Bro, no!
I just saw an upgrade, so I got inject Super Chat into my
veins.
Man, thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
I ruined it!
No!
I got too greedy!
I saw I went level 5 and never looked back.
You've changed Doki ever since you went to level 5 super
chat You've changed all those bank accounts changed you
Alright, let's see I got so greedy I got way too greedy The
greed I can't I drank the Halu What even is Halu I got...
All right.
Oh, wait.
Do we do horn or bucket?
I missed the old toky.
One.
Oh my god.
Jesus.
Okay.
I guess we'll go a full bucket.
And then horn or crit up.
Chat.
Horn or corn?
horn is great no need horn horn three i'll do horn then horn
oh my god there's so much more horn oh fuck okay follow me
all healing is doubled oh credit card cost of enhancing is
reduced but uh i guess spider cooking or upgrade my stuff
credit card or spider cooking all right oh my god there's
still more i guess we'll go bucket since we're almost there
about five times in a row and I did not upgrade.
I was not.
I was not picking up anything.
I can't upgrade greed.
Oh, no.
Big boy is coming.
All right, get rid of marking.
Should I swap marking for this?
I'm going to swap and then strengthen greed.
Upgrade.
Okay, upgrade.
Strength.
Nice.
It's fine.
We have...
Bomb.
We have Bomb.
Go, go, go, bomb.
Go, go, go bomb.
You got this.
All right, bomb is gone.
Oh, whoa, whoa!
Okay.
All right, I'm getting damage so fucking hard right now.
Is this the halftime boss?
This is...
This is the halftime boss.
Holy shit.
Bro, he's raining money for me, though.
he's actually raining money it's raining money let's go this
is the power level four super chats this is i feel so strong
i've changed i've changed okay let's grab the box what do i
get nice we need that what happened to you doki ever since
what is this weapon hits have uh Sorry, sorry, the greed
caught me so fast that I don't even know what level I'm on.
I'm shrunk off all the bank accounts.
There's so many.
Okay, swap, and then we upgrade.
We upgrade bomb, right?
Greed level, we swap upgrade three.
Okay, nice.
All right, nice.
Oh my god, there was this...
conversation earlier about the fucking okay i was gonna say
to give context as to how how fucking crazy 400 000 is like
450 000 for the sphere it is 20 000 for one day by the way
the sphere is one day 450 000 and then um for one week on um
i think was it um in shibuya station uh in tokyo is twenty
thousand dollars for one week like that's that's how
expensive i'm heading to the arrow look at all these rats i
have to kill all the rats first okay let me a sec uh all
right what do we upgrade here we go oh i'll create the
upgrade uh the blast all right and then oh my god i got
weapon will fire there is no other effect it will fire
backwards okay what do we upgrade here
um um sp thank you for the five gift the ships Thank you.
Thank you.
Strengthen too?
Okay, strengthen.
Alright.
We're fine.
Is there any more arrows?
Okay, there's no more arrows.
We should be good.
Holy shit.
We're so fucking strong right now.
Stage 1 is actually baby.
Oh, fuck.
Alright.
Start cooking.
We haven't got like the collab stuff yet, though.
I need to grab the collapse.
Now I know why people can stream hours of this game.
I don't know why watch like the vaude like see the vaude
time stamp of this game and it's like uh five plus hours i
understand now i understand i get it now chat i figured it
out this is very addicting guys i know my directions i'm
heading down for once in my life i figured out where to go
wait we're at two hours i've been playing this game for two
hours now fuck!
Jesus, okay.
Okay, this might be a problem.
I did not feel the two hours.
Not gonna...
Wait, is this good?
Attacks have 20% chance at, uh...
Let's see.
Yeah, I can...
I should upgrade this.
Alright.
To upgrade, right?
It has that...
Uh...
Alright, well...
Because I'm...
I didn't know if I should if I should oh my god I'm so rich
I'm so rich I can finally upgrade you know I remember like
when you guys kept yelling at me to upgrade stats like when
you guys would sell stats and I thought that you meant like
the talent the talent has really good stats and that's what
I thought you meant when you guys kept yelling stats at me
and not because of when in reality you were telling me to
purchase my stat upgrades
I couldn't tell.
Yeah, I was like, what's the context?
I was like, why does my chat keep yelling stats at me?
I don't understand.
Why would they keep yelling that?
Is it because the talents have really good stats in general?
Like, what is the context?
Where the fuck is the context?
Alright, we'll do, we'll max up the cooking.
You know what?
Are I sure about this?
I am so sure.
Bro, this is fucking baby shit.
I'm so sure.
Alright.
Do we get bandage?
We're doing it.
We are, we're, we're so fucking, look at that.
$6,000 now.
I have like so many bank accounts in my, I mean, I have, I
have so many bank accounts now.
Don't...
I'm gonna do it!
What's the worst that's gonna happen?
Alright, now this is all new.
I don't know what to get.
I'm locked in.
I am full on Halu now.
Look at those.
I'm fucking drunk with power.
I'm at level 5, Super Shadow.
Why is chat yelling?
Are they stupid?
Thank you for the Super Chat.
Thank you.
Alright, one or four.
We'll do...
we'll do four okay what's the worst that could happen anyway
i'm so much money like come on we're gonna do nothing where
the fuck is the collab anvil all right what do we upgrade
chat already upgraded the blast i know but i have to i have
to kill i have to get the one up i need to I need to go up
before I can go down.
I need to go up before I can go down.
Wait, did I just accidentally paid for that?
Right here.
Oh my gosh.
No regrets.
Wait, what's that?
Peaky peeky?
Wait, is this good?
I don't know if I should get this.
I haven't grabbed this before.
We grabbed this or nah.
Take it?
It's called investment?
Is it good?
Take it, okay.
I believe.
I trust you guys.
There's no way you guys would fuck me over.
Unlike all the other times you guys fucked me over.
This time there's no way you guys would fuck me over.
Okay.
Compared to all the other times you guys try to fuck me
over.
There's no way this time it'll work.
We would never...
It was not one guide!
I literally see!
Two for collab?
Two?
Okay.
Alright, what do we get, chat?
What do we upgrade?
It's not one guide if it was multiple guides.
It could be multiple one guides, though.
uh two or three upgrade two and three okay we'll do we'll do
two upgrade first all right nice we're good now all right
and then what do we get here uh do we upgrade the piki or
the bomb i think it was multiple two guys you need level
seven weapons for collab thank you super chat master thank
you thank you Three?
Three.
Okay, this is five.
There is so many sparkles up here.
Jesus Christ.
Oh, no.
What's coming down?
Okay.
Oh, my God.
Okay, I need to...
All right.
I need to get rid of the...
There's way too much flashes.
Okay.
This is a visual effects.
Okay, let's see.
Okay.
Is it the visual effects for that?
Oh my god, yeah, there we go.
There's like, that was like way too many flashes.
That was like insane.
Alright, there we go.
The numbers, what do they mean?
What do the numbers mean?
Can I fix my settings?
I don't remember.
Alright.
Wait, wait, what if I do damage?
reflexes is was it yeah it was let's get rid of that no the
numbers we're fine now now it's not flashing anymore all
right let's increase damage by five percent for each weapon
okay we maxed everything yeah we don't we can sell this nice
all right there's another arrow below me oh no Okay, we'll
grab this.
Okay, oh no, I'm trying to go down.
Oh my
god, they're so fast!
Guys!
Okay, we're fine.
Oh, okay.
Okay, I forgot the Halu shit.
I forgot the Halu shit.
three okay okay we're gonna this is bad this is bad i should
not have guys i should not guys i realize that maybe i
should not have went full in a hallowe i should not have
went full in a hallowe oh my god did it oh my god i can't
magnet there's so many there's so many it's gonna take
forever to get the magnet chat please oh god please Ah!
Fucking don't go full hallowe!
Guys, never go full hallowe.
I made my mistakes.
I can't believe it.
When the upgrade said, don't do it.
Why did I do it?
Who would have thought?
When it says don't do it, you should not do it.
I can't believe it.
Oh my god.
Okay, two.
There are two bombs.
Okay.
Oh my god, it's okay.
We got the box.
Axe?
Do we pick up the axe?
Should we pick up the axe?
It's always go full up.
Yeah?
Drop?
Okay.
Yes.
I see more takes than drops.
All right.
What's this?
Oh, I got another axe.
Nice.
Okay.
We don't need to take that magnet.
We already have, like, way too many magnets anyway.
We have more than in the magnets chat.
All right.
It's fine.
It is.
Oh, my God.
It might not be.
be fine it might not be fine oh my god oh shit we're okay
i'm following the arrows
oh my god three or four four okay okay uh we might as well
grab the axe okay there's a hammer i don't know what the
hammer does what did that do what did i do i just walked
over it and I don't know what happened.
What the fuck does the hammer do?
What did it do?
I can't tell.
It's a super collab?
Oh, okay.
Nothing, okay.
Yes, you are.
I can't believe the devs didn't warn me about Halu.
I can't believe it.
Why didn't they warn me when...
How could they not do that?
I can't believe it.
Okay, we're gonna just keep going.
Oh, there's a green over here.
Let's grab the green first.
Oh, there's the green.
Attacks have 20% chance to reduce attack and defense of
targets, but that right we don't need that why would it it's
like the bicycle meme you know when you're riding the
bicycle and then it's like upgrade halloo and i was like why
would the devs do this did i stick the stick into my bicycle
how could the devs do this to me
Oh, no, I'm trying.
Okay, we're gonna try and figure out how to get to the other
side.
Oh my god, there's the anvil, but I can't do anything about
it.
There's a trumpet, too.
There's too many things on my screen.
There's a way.
All right, nice.
We got...
Okay, we can...
Doot, doot, doot.
Uh...
We have to save our ultimate.
Let's see.
What do we do?
Swap 2?
For the projectile stamp?
Or sell it?
Or do we wait for...
Swap 2?
Okay, swap.
Confirm.
And then...
Strengthen.
Yeah.
There you go.
Okay, and then we're gonna grab this Anvil.
Let's see.
Do we get...
I guess we can Uh, and then we'll do The bubbly bomb Yeah,
we gotta grab the trumpet Give me a sec Oh my god Holy shit,
he's so strong Okay, we're gonna Okay, we're so slow We are
so slow right now Oh my god, we actually need to be faster
You're not the trumpet
Oh my god, you're not the trumpet oh my god uh all right i'm
gonna upgrade wait is it max i already maxed it out okay
we're gonna drop this for now i'm gonna drop this for now we
get to get the trumpet uh max okay oh my god we're so we are
so i can't get the trump but there's so many people.
I'm so slow.
Oh, no.
Oh, please have a speed somewhere.
Okay.
Max.
I maxed the bomb.
There's the collapse.
Okay.
Alright.
We're gonna...
What do we replace?
Swap 2.
Okay.
We swap 2.
And then...
Wait, do we...
Don't even... Wait, do we swap to...
Okay.
Don't keep...
Wait, wait, wait, what is with salad?
There is no way!
You made me risk my life!
Boring!
Do...
You try to take advantage of me?
Wait...
We almost...
God...
He said it's it literally said weapon will sound like a
trumpet there is no weapon You guys are so close you guys
almost got me you guys you guys almost got me You guys
almost got me I can't believe it I could have sold this a
long time ago I can't believe you you almost got me to do
Holy shit!
Guys!
Alright, we're fine.
We're so fucking fine.
We're the fucking super collab!
Oh god, oh okay.
Super collab time.
Limited time.
Only 5,000 yen.
Oh god, I'm so slow.
I'm so slow.
Can't be out of here.
Oh my god, we need more speed.
Everybody's so fast.
Okay, we have to go around.
It's okay.
At least we have like, holy shit.
The only thing that's saving me right now is the fact that
my attack has knockback because everybody's faster than me.
Everybody is so fucking fast.
Okay.
Okay, we got, do we take this or of course now she decides
to read yo cat thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you i'm literally living because of my knockback there's
nothing else that's fucking keeping me alive increase attack
size by 15 is that good or not the dude would have been
better no but thank you for the super chat chat thank you
thank you this win been problem you haven't skipped on the
dude thank you over in the super chat thank you thank you oh
my god he angie i'm so fucking angie now i'm trying so hard
to figure out to like maybe hope that we get hope that we
can get grab a fucking magnet right now this is not good for
me it is not good okay here we go Don't worry.
I have knockback.
They can't fuck their... They might be faster.
But I have the power of knockback.
Oh my god.
Imagine the amount of money I would have made.
If I played endless mode.
I should have played endless mode.
I didn't...
Oh my god.
I could have made so much money!
Bro, this was the money.
Moneymaker!
This was...
This was the moneymaker round!
Woo!
Oh no.
This is an issue right now.
This is a problem.
This is...
This is a huge problem.
Oh no.
This is pretty bad.
No!
And there was a pillar!
It was a pillar chat I got hit I hit the pillar I hit the
pillar One pillar is all it took It was so close Okay maybe
we'll get Wait what is it Is Risu also meta?
Where's Risu?
Okay Risu's also meta right?
I'm not gonna do 31 What?
Risu is super meta?
What makes her super meta?
Oh, it's also...
Okay, it's also a...
Risu is good for money.
Okay, what is good for endgame?
Which one is...
Which one is endgame material?
No doki, dude, sad trumpet noise.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
Damn.
Promise has, like, super- all the meta characters.
Alright, where the fuck is, Promise?
There you go.
Alright, we'll do...
We'll do two.
Maybe two.
It'll be fine.
Come on.
Are you-
How's this possible?
Okay.
It can't happen twice in a row.
It can't happen three times in a row, right?
Okay, we're at the pity stage.
Let's go.
We're at the pity stage.
Alright, there we go.
We're at the pity now.
We're at the pity!
Let's go!
Wait, no.
Okay, we have pity.
Oh, it's Fauna or Mume.
That's my Oshi.
Just use the tears.
Okay.
I can't believe it.
I can't fucking believe it.
I can't believe I had to pity pull for Mume.
Like, I can't fucking believe.
I have to pity pull for her.
That's so fucked up.
This is why I don't do gotcha.
I swear to fucking
Oh my god, look how much I can upgrade her.
Alright, let's get some stats now.
Let's grab.
Let's grab stats.
Bro, okay.
Okay, I don't need luck.
I earn everything with sheer determination and hard work.
I don't need luck
Okay, I need a note like Like I make my luck Okay, it has to
be two attacks Alright, let me grab the two attacks real
fast Alright, any XP and coins Coin XP Pick up rain This
last word Okay, I can upgrade, I can max everything Oh
Upgrade growth?
Where the fuck is growth?
What does that mean?
Max out which one?
Where do I have speed?
Okay, what do we max out?
Upgrade coin game?
Special, okay, coin game.
Okay.
And then...
Um...
What else?
Enhancements?
Oh!
Bro!
Should I max it out?
Here's the damage of character in the special attacks by 1%.
Should I do it again?
Or nah?
I mean, I could do it one more.
Get to level 2?
Yeah?
Alright, we'll do level 2.
I mean, we still have enough money.
And then...
What else do we get?
I don't know...
I can't fucking believe.
I can't...
fucking...
I paid to get another Mume.
That's actually like, how?
How is that fucking possible?
How is that actually possible?
Holy shit.
MHP regen.
I'll do that.
And then I already got fandom.
Yeah, I got it.
Haste.
I already got... I don't have enough for another Haste.
I don't have 50,000.
Crit?
I'll grab crit.
I mean, I have like...
Crit, XP, uh, pick up, and...
take HP.
You know what?
I'll take double HP.
And then I'll do more...
Uh...
Let's see.
What do you mean I have no haste?
I do!
Wait, where's haste?
Wait, guys, I don't have haste.
I don't know why, but, like, I, I, like, assume when you say
haste, you just try to say speed.
And I was like, maybe that's a British thing.
I don't know.
Maybe you guys are just trying, like, just saying haste,
which means speed.
I was like, guys, I do have haste.
It's time three.
um let's see what else defense all right we'll do defense we
can do another defense too we might as well all right there
you go this is this is our loadout let's go all right mume
take me take me to the hollow office i believe in you i
believe in you mume you can't fail me we still have um Joki,
we don't say haste in the UK, we said swift.
Learn the difference.
Joki, words have specific meaning.
Nice.
Okay, oh, bloodthirsty.
What the fuck?
It's him.
It's moving time.
Do you have one or three?
Three?
All right.
I guess because that's like her main attack, right?
uh we'll apply I assume that's because it's like her main
attack and then I'll just max out her main attack for now
yeah I'll max out her main just in case alright nice I can't
believe I can't believe how much I can't believe I couldn't
I can't believe I got fucked over by a pillar That's the
only reason why I die.
Oh my god.
Why did the devs not warn me about Halu?
Why didn't they stop me?
They could have said something.
They could have said anything to stop me.
Okay, here we go.
Of course my second power-up is dude.
Here's your dokey dudes
Here you go Here's your doot time Oh no Please tell me I can
go
It's already It's already over
I don't know I'm all over It's a curse It's It's just the
most Unluckiest person You know what maybe like it's it's
i'm just the most unlucky person here like of course all
right here you go
i'm just i was just never meant to be lucky i told you i
don't have luck i'll make my own luck through hard it's just
through hard work and through termination i'm just i'm not
lucky i just way in through life.
massing.
The dude of fate.
Strength.
What happens when you strengthen dudes?
Do you just do more?
Is that it?
No money, just a dude.
Do I just... Do I just do more?
Like, what the fuck happens?
It's just louder, dudes.
Alright, here we go.
Boop.
Jesus Christ, you're so tanky.
Alright.
That's fine.
Now I just know, never go down to that corner because it's
never a good idea.
I'm getting the hang of knowing what the offices look like
now.
Just do it harder.
Doki, just do it harder.
Not that difficult.
Just keep do it.
Alright, let's see.
We gotta max out the feather.
Okay.
Oh no, please.
Please.
Oh my god.
Oh wait, I can just run past that.
Increase damage.
Well, that's good for now.
Because I don't have any.
Oh my god, please.
I don't have any anyways.
So that's good.
Okay, we're gonna...
Oh my god, we're doing even...
We're doing faster!
Oh god.
This is it.
Do.
Now I know...
Now I know why.
Okay, I have a song, Attack Up.
We get Nurse's Horn.
The Multiple Dudes.
Or the Glasses.
The Glasses?
The Glasses.
Okay.
Alright.
Holy shit, it's so fast now.
This is so fast.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Are you a mini boss?
I think that's it.
Oh!
What the fuck?
What does that do?
What the fuck does they all do?
I got Mooma scared.
Alright, glasses.
Oh.
Oh, and I got a box.
Nice.
Oh, it says Screen White.
Delete everyone.
Oh!
This is good.
Magical music notes that float vertically in both
Directions.
Is that good?
Take?
Okay.
Yeah, I got...
I got Muma jump scared.
What is this?
Increased damage or weapon, I might as well.
Yeah.
Oh my god, it's flying everywhere.
Alright.
I have more of her ult now.
This is... I'm so prepared.
I'm so prepared.
Get ready for this.
Boom.
Oh, nice.
Upgrade.
Free upgrade.
Uh, I guess I'll upgrade Idol sign?
I mean, there's nothing else to upgrade right now.
Let's see.
Glasses?
Oh, yeah, I should upgrade glasses because it's, like,
strong XP, right?
Boop, boop, boop, boop.
God, this is my brain right now.
I can't commentate because all I could think about is
like...
This is my brain on holo cure.
Passivist stamp.
I'm gonna swap this and then...
Intense focus.
When you stop using the trumpet, you'll miss it.
listen okay fine i'll weapon will do it harder okay fine
fine is that what you wanted i'm giving you guys what you
want the booster dudes oh my god is is doing so hard right
now
okay uh do we upgrade Gap, boost the dudes.
One or two?
Uh, I see more twos.
I'm gonna do two.
I see more twos than ones.
You know what's crazy?
This game is like, not even...
This game is not even, like, the file size is not even that
big.
That's actually really, like...
What's the word?
Uh, also, strings!
Thank you for the Akasupa!
Thank you.
Dude.
Especially when, like, AAA gaming don't know how to
fucking...
Don't know how to, like, fucking stabilize game sizes.
Yeah, it's, like, so well optimized.
Like, a lot of AAA devs do not know how to fucking optimize
games these days.
And the fact that this game is the... I don't remember what
the file size was, but I remember when I was, like,
downloading it, I was, like, holy shit at like how small the
game is compared to like because i know there's like lots of
content too in holocure okay let's see i guess i get glasses
nice and we got the music notes too just get a way big armor
yeah you can tell a key is a like because I still can't
believe I still can't believe the Star Wars classic
battlefront is like how many gigabytes was that 80 plus
gigabytes or was it less than that like 75 75 gigabytes no
friend oh there's Ben so I'm gonna friend that uses bed for
feather at okay I'll get friend friend it's time it's time
to help me yeah over 70 gigabytes which is insane for like a
game that's supposed to be classic and like apparently the
reason why oh god please don't hurt me please don't touch me
i don't like social interactions the reason why is that they
forgot to like resize the textures in the game how do you
forget to resize the textures It wasn't even for a holiday.
I don't understand.
Okay, let's see.
What do we get?
Civilization.
I guess we could do civilization.
Let's max that out.
Is there another arrow?
Let's go to my left.
Like, I don't understand if they want to have the game out
in time for Christmas or something.
Or for...
Oh my god, life steal!
Guys, I don't know, guys.
I don't know, guys.
I like how everybody was like, swap to upgrade that dude.
Swap three.
Okay.
The things I do for the goons are things I do.
dude oh my god
always upgrade dude all right it will be harmful if this
dude's any louder dude put up put up
god the dude it must go on all right let's see oh my god
super Super chat time!
Dude's end super chat time!
Just dude.
I think he's like, no, three or four guys.
Okay, guys, think about the money.
Think about the money though.
What the money?
Think about the money.
Super chat.
No, no, this is level one super chat.
level 1 super chats actually cost money guys guys we can't
guys level 1 super chat is the money super chat hey guys
thank you the super chat thank you thank you no you use your
real money you had to wait until we're at level 4 oh wait
i'm gonna wipe this out and so i can take care of him first
Please chill.
Alright, let's see.
Dude.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Trading, thank you for the super chat.
Two?
Are you the sign?
Or one?
One.
I see a lot of...
Okay, I'm gonna do...
I'm gonna do...
One.
Alright.
Oh, fuck!
That's a one!
My last dude.
I can't tell.
That's a wall.
It's so hard to tell.
I don't understand.
Do I have a dove?
Okay, maybe this time I'll get Fauna.
Maybe this time.
Okay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay.
I got counters, dude.
Alright, look.
Apparently, guys, look, it's not a crutch.
Okay, we're gonna look.
Okay, maybe, okay, maybe we can do this.
As long as we don't keep getting too tired.
No, we don't deserve the house.
We need to defeat the office.
We don't deserve it.
No, my goodness.
Guys, it's the dude crutch.
It's the fucking duke curse, okay?
It's because we kept getting dueted on.
Always stay centered.
Yeah, I know.
I just realized that, like, maybe, like, going to the edges
is not a good idea.
Who would have thought?
The duke curse, it's real.
Be careful.
When you pick up the duke, you can never go back.
The run is over.
The moment you start duding, the run is over.
It's not as a cost as you don't give up.
Oh my god, no, I'm not at the center.
I'm not at the center.
Okay, it's okay, we're fine.
We're slowly adjusting.
Oh wait, there's a...
Okay, this is very risky.
But, oh my god, okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
We just gotta keep moving forward.
This is it.
Oh, there's no...
Okay, what do we get here?
Institute cause.
Three?
Okay.
We get three.
Oh, we're gonna back out a little bit, though.
We're gonna back out a little bit.
Ow.
That's fine.
We're fine.
Oh, box.
Another box.
That's just burger.
We don't need the burger, though.
Should be fine without it.
Uh...
feather.
We gotta get all the feathers.
For the ultimate.
We gotta max out the feathers.
I'm figuring out the meta.
Very slowly.
It's okay.
The moment we max out the feathers, we can go.
We can start gaming for reels.
Ooh, the flower.
What's the flower?
Tax to have 20% chance to reduce.
Okay, nice.
We got that.
You don't need the burger.
We're perfectly healthy.
Look at us.
We're perfectly healthy, guys.
Like, That said, Cali was not a crutch.
We can replicate it.
Alright, nice.
Now we have maxed out.
We will be able to replicate.
I swear to God.
It's possible.
Do I take this?
Do we take the plug?
The moment I beat a sage, we might only be able to beat
sages on Cali, but like...
the moment we can be another stage with a different talent
that's when you know that's when you know i can game with
any fucking character
uh let's see do we do we level up or do we do we should
level up i'm gonna level up actually i'm gonna level up i
feel like that's good to do all right see what do we take
guys one two three four which one
one all right one it's okay we're gonna do this we're gonna
beat we're gonna toho this shit toho i swear toho has to be
i'm apparently someone said i can get an achievement if i
stand here for 10 seconds am i not in front of this
yay that was definitely longer than 10 seconds I don't care
I don't need this but like I just need one win in my life I
need one win all right let's see save seconds are longer
than real seconds all right we'll grab one I swear I get one
guys we'll grab god damn it the fucking pot Right here,
yeah.
Oh, wait.
Get over here.
Give me your money.
I'll create the pug.
Because I won't get a weapon closer for a collab.
I think I have...
Yeah, three.
I might as well.
No, we do not.
We do not want...
We do not want Halu.
Alright.
two three four which one do we get which one chat one okay i
guess we can replace wait oh i'll replace i'll replace this
and then what do we strengthen here
do we strengthen the flower or the one the palette green
okay we'll strengthen All strength and greed.
Might as well.
Yeah.
Oh my guys.
Guys, three minutes.
We're at this.
But like, I swear toho, I just don't know.
There's just too, I think like, I just get like way too...
When there's just too many things on my screen, I just
can't.
I like, panic so fucking hard.
There's just too many balls.
Don't you just hate it when there's just too many balls on
the screen?
Like, come on.
Anybody.
Anybody would freak out!
Alright.
Understandable.
Me every day.
Okay.
So we have this.
Hey, who's coming over?
Whoa.
Nice.
It's juiced.
Oh my god, there's too many things around now.
We're making good progress this time.
I think it's also because I'm not getting distracted by the
dudes.
The dudes aren't hurting me.
Do you actually read chat?
No, I do not.
This is all pre-recorded.
My psych...
If you guys don't know, I have a psychic and they tell me
what you're going to say in advance so um so this stream was
pre-recorded uh this this stream was pre-recorded like uh
last week um because like everything is everything is staged
it's just like reality tv i knew it
that's right you're oh she every vtuber do not quote me on
this um every yes i also use chat gpt and i would be like
chat gpt i'm going to stream um i'm going to publish my
holocure uh my holocure bot next week what what will i have
to prepare for for my chat 50 percent student do i take this
or nah do i do i in the psychic Toki to read exactly geo
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you Take okay,
and then my mod is gonna be like disclaimer.
This is a bit.
This is not a bit This whole entire stream has been I swear
to fucking god.
I'm walking away.
I
Okay, um, we're gonna we're gonna walk over there real fast
Okay, wait, what's... Oh, it's just the flying.
We're fine.
Everything is fine.
If I keep going right, it's like I don't see it.
What arrow?
What arrow are you guys talking about?
There's no arrows anywhere.
What?
What arrows are you talking about?
But anyway, as I was saying, it's crazy.
AI is too strong now.
AI has predicted the future for streaming.
All I do is just be like, chat GPT.
uh what is my what is my chat gonna tell me today when i
stream holo here and then they're gonna be like oh dok
they're gonna be like um in dokibird's holoq here stream
there is going to be what do i upgrade i guess i'll upgrade
greed there is go wait actually is this even good increase
attack size do we need attack size
is that good i'm actually in chat gpt by the way uh
chat GPT is is this good I'm if you see me looking to the
right is actually the chat GPT screen because because
obviously I can't reach out because it's pre-recorded okay
we are you guys are a chat GPT let's see I feel like, too.
Civilization.
Nice.
Good job, friend.
Okay, as I was saying, uh, that actually shows how good of a
streamer I am.
That it just feels so real.
Oh my god, she's so good at streaming that it doesn't even
feel like it's pre-recorded.
I know!
It doesn't!
I'm gonna grab before it because I need a...
AI is true.
Oh my god, did you guys hear about the dead internet theory?
Does it...
Like, every... If you ever look at, like, popular posts
from, like, big Twitter accounts, uh, there'd be, like, it's
just bots.
It's because of, like, because of Elon Musk's fucking, like,
oh, like, advertising, fucking monetization shit.
For those who don't know what the dead internet theory is,
let me open this box first.
It's just, the world is becoming more and more infested in
bots.
like in the internet yeah it's just all up internet they
just they actually use chat gpt and ai to make twitter
responses it's so fucking weird it's so weird holy shit it's
like y2k it's like modern day y2k um buddy friend you only
have three oh sorry it's like chat is just my entire chat is
just it's just ai so like if you ever go on like those
popular like meme twitter accounts or not just like news
twitter accounts or like just like wait what achievement
don't take any damage for five seconds oh shit i did it i'm
fucking gaming uh but basically like they actually use like
oh wait okay oh my god but they're super chat time okay
become high mind and chat GPT all our base blood on the chat
GPT say thank you the super chat thank you thank you it's
actually so scary though because you don't know like like i
think they haven't targeted vtubers yet like vtubers are not
targeted yet like viral posts but you ever look no my five
minute not take damage but but you ever look at any viral
post or anything mostly just like bot accounts and the
reason why they do that is because they can sell twitter
accounts to like for oh fuck upgrade sorry give me a sec
this is this is important um oh nice uh what do we get here
what do we get here i mean it's not we're not talking about
like link in bio
in bio shit is like actual like replies to your tweets it's
like replies to your tweets that feel like real people type
responses to it because they're trying to get reactions to
it and stuff and then oh whoa Pull in the wall It's not that
it's like actual viral tweets that have like that are like
there to like get likes and follows and um even like like if
we started on youtube because it's like the mr b shit um god
what do we want super shadow time or blood firsty what do we
want do we invite you
okay here you go but like it's because like the reason why
they do that is because And they're always verified too.
They're always verified to take advantage of the
monetization for Elon Musk shit.
Because they're like, oh, if we have like a viral tweet,
then like, oh my god, get out!
Leave!
Stop!
Okay, sorry.
So many things are going on right now.
The reason why.
And also they can sell Twitter accounts for money as well.
uh all right do we get three or four this stream is very
interesting thank you for being for a super chat kid thank
you thank you tomato and pie or two wait three or four three
three okay all right and then we can i guess we'll okay max
level this what is this okay we might as well because it's
already half book so people can sell twitter like twitter
accounts as well because the more followers you know it's
like what is it what was that twitter account there was this
really big popular twitter accounts oh yeah images before
they became popular so there was this really big twitter
account that was like images before they became viral or
some shit and that guy sold his twitter account for like 10
000 or something that's fucking crazy because it was like uh
Yeah, because then they like named they like the Twitter
account suddenly changed into some NFT shit or something
Like that's like like they suddenly changed into some NFT
shit and then people were like what the fuck Yeah, origins
of iconic like iconic like yeah that shit and then Yeah,
they fucking sold it and then the guy was like yeah, I've
had offers uh like or crypto it was either nft or crypto and
they're like they're like yeah it got like i've and then
other popular twitter accounts were like yeah we get like
lots of offers for we get like a shitload of offers for uh
for like my twitter account that has like i don't know 500k
followers or some shit i don't know like and then it's like
you people would want to buy the account Oh, hey, look.
What's this?
Projectile sound.
Oh, wait, projectile sound.
That's really good.
Let's see.
What is that?
Swap one?
Swap.
Okay, and then we'll swap this.
And then we'll...
I guess we'll strengthen one.
We'll sneak it out.
Okay, what I'm really worried about is bomb guy.
Bomb guy freaks me out yeah i mean it's the same thing with
uh fuck they did that with youtube accounts too where they
get to a hundred is that desk oh okay i was like what the
fuck is that they do that with like youtube accounts as well
they try to get it to like a hundred k uh like back then
when the whole there was like a meta where oh my god big oh
i'm not fast i'm not I'm fast.
I'm fast enough.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Oh, no.
Okay, don't worry.
I'm fast enough, though.
Okay, I'm just gonna... I'm just gonna be over here.
Give me a sec.
Oh, my God.
What is the range?
I need to get into an open space.
This is bad.
I'm not, like, in an open... Oh, my God.
Okay.
I'm... I'm...
I don't want to look at this.
Get me out of here.
No, I don't see.
I don't perceive.
If I don't look, it's like it doesn't exist.
If I don't look, it's not there.
Yeah, that's how I'm going to go with it.
life.
Just don't look.
If I don't look, it doesn't exist.
I might as well max that out.
Oh, three!
I might as well take all of that.
Yeah.
The cooking and the super shadow.
And then we enhance.
Might as well enhance the... Well, enhance the book.
Let's see.
You cannot...
I'm ready!
You can't stop me!
Oh shit, collab!
Nice.
I got the collab time.
But yeah, back then, back then, the meta for YouTube
accounts was to be everywhere with comments.
So, like, you'd be like...
Alright.
Do we strengthen this?
Or do we swap this?
We can max out the the the we can snap
get gorilla paw okay get gorilla paw swap swap two okay swap
two all right and we'll strengthen confirm but yeah back you
know like back in old youtube the meta was to like have just
oh shit oh my god okay here we go okay we're gonna max up
book just to have with YouTube comments.
So every YouTube viral YouTube video, you see like the same
five people commenting on YouTube.
And then they'll sell their accounts afterwards.
Because it's like so, that's like easy subscribers.
It was just so easy to get subscribers.
And then they'll sell the YouTube account.
And then there's like free YouTube play button.
Like free, like, Head Start and stuff for those who are
like, Like, they'll sell it to, like, all...
They'll sell it to, like, some fucking content creator that
wants, like, more subscribers or something.
And then, like...
And then, at one point, they were, like...
It started hacking other channels, too.
They were, like, hacking YouTube channels so they can sell
the YouTube channels and stuff for money.
It's fucking crazy.
Let's see.
Do we want... We don't want this, right?
Do we want this or nah?
Do we strengthen it?
Upgrade 2 Okay It's crazy Things people will do for money
It's actually insane But yeah This is why This is why like
No we're back in that trumpet Why do I keep coming back to
you We get the gorilla paw right guys Now they just hacked
them to show NFT scams Yeah or crypto scams you get the
monkey paw right the gorilla paw two okay we'll grab two and
then we'll have a super collab oh god i cannot see anything
i cannot oh no we're at the stage where i can't see anything
i always come back to that trumpet why can i never quit you
why can i never quit you oh okay oh here we go it's fine
Everything is fine.
We're at the center.
We're all okay.
Okay, we'll get to the spot of cooking.
Just sell the trumpet.
No, it's here to punish you all.
So you know, wherever I go, you will know where that green
arrow is.
Everywhere I go, you will know what this green arrow is.
Just to tempt all of you guys forever.
You'll always be there.
Taunting you.
Telling you to be like, I'm here.
I'm here.
I'm right here.
The doot.
Get ready for the doots.
Alright, let's see.
What do I get?
here.
Do I just max out Gorilla Paul?
Awesome, logical.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Watching you play inspired me to get the game.
I beat the first stage, which I'm in.
Just beat the second with Gorilla.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Right?
We maxed the Paul for the okay, maxed the Paul for the super
collab.
Alright, that's fine.
That's good to know.
Alright, here we go.
Oh yeah, I was trying to fucking do a Zatsuba haul HoloFest.
I almost forgot.
There's just so many things happening on my screen.
But oh my... Okay, wait.
Let me think real fast.
Okay.
But yeah, it's actually...
Like, I don't know if they did, like, personal...
Oh, fuck, wait.
Give me a sec, guys.
There's two...
I'll never be able to talk about HoloFest because there's
always things happening.
Okay, what do we want?
One, two, three, four.
Boy?
an axe?
Or two?
Four?
Okay, we'll get four.
What is this open?
Axe!
Alright, that's good.
We just got the axe, too.
What is this?
Reduce special cooldown by 45%.
Allows a special... Do we get this?
Or nah.
Take or nah?
Is this a take?
Oh, okay.
This is super rare.
Oh my gosh, my luck changing.
This is it.
My luck is turning around.
This is it, Moomey!
We're doing it!
My lock is finally turning around!
It's here!
Holy shit.
It's actually here.
Oh my god.
Alright, here we go.
But no, I'm like...
Oh my god.
Fuck!
Please!
I'll never...
I'll never be able to talk about holo I grew up huh
everything is just too many things on my screen We're too
close Too close.
I like people were like just all so we can hear their
tangents Doki just fucking all We want to know about what
you think about holo fest just all No.
No.
I want the money.
I want the money, though.
Fine.
But it doesn't give me the money.
But it just went.
It's like that screen wipe thing.
Guys, it doesn't.
I want to have the money.
The money is so good.
Yeah, move.
Like, it all sucks.
I hate the...
I don't like...
Oh, wait.
okay never mind okay never mind this is good that's good now
there was just way too many batteries oh no is this like the
wait i gotta grab the axe here and then what the money guys
how am i supposed to beat toho if i don't get rich here in
hollow cure how the am i supposed to beat beat toho that's
actually my greatest weakness toho Alright, we gotta kill
the battery.
Nice.
Battery gun.
Okay.
Monkey paw?
Three!
Oh.
Super energy drink.
Wait, is this really good?
Wait, this is... Is this an SSR?
Oh, shit.
Nice.
Now I'm super fast.
Wait, there's four arrows?
What the fuck did I... Oh, I'm so fucking fast.
Oh my god.
I'm so fucking fast.
Okay, can we max... Okay, we're gonna sell this.
Alright, I'm gonna sell this chat no
i finished upgrading everything i'm pretty sure yeah
everything's maxed all right i knew it i knew my luck was
gonna change woman i always believed in you i told you the
dude is the curse i fucking knew it i fucking knew it i knew
it i fucking knew the dudes were the curse All this time.
God.
Never took the trumpet.
Suddenly get two SSRs.
Coincidence?
I think not.
I knew it.
I knew it was a fucking curse in the end.
I fucking called it.
Where the fuck is the bomb?
I'm like so worried about the bomb right now.
Oh!
Oh, okay.
I was not.
I was not doing so well with that.
I need that burger.
Please give me that burger.
Super collab!
What is it?
Wait, what do we combine?
What do we combine here?
What do we combine?
Dragon fire.
Wait.
No super...
Dragon fire.
Okay.
Axe plus book.
Alright, it's time to eat some black licorice again.
Alright, here we go.
Nice.
Alright.
Oh my god, I can't see anything.
Okay.
Okay, we actually have to tone this down now.
This is like too much.
This is actually too much on my screen.
Holy fuck.
Okay, we need to grab.
Oh, hey.
We need to...
Is this good?
Okay, we installed this.
Oh, I don't have hammer.
Yeah, I need to find a hammer.
That green thing over there, that's the dude.
If I keep it there, I'll have good luck.
Uh...
Let's see.
One, two, three, four.
Pirate, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Take that.
I'm back.
Alright.
Uh.
Head foot?
Like, lava?
Okay.
I don't know why I said hammer.
I meant lava.
Uh.
My brain is not working so well.
I've been playing holo cure for like three hours already.
Woo!
Hammer!
I got the hammer!
Guys, we just need a monkey paw!
Oh god.
Oh.
Do I take this now?
Do I wait until monkey paw?
Do I take that now or wait?
Now?
Okay.
What do I do?
This?
Monkey paw!
Okay.
That's it?
Is that it?
Yeah?
Oh, okay.
What do I get?
Holy fire.
Spits flames which contains the strength of 50 kg.
Attack damage is also multiplied.
Holy shit.
Alright.
Oh my god.
Come get Super Chat.
Now Super Chat's free for sure.
Oh no.
Okay.
Uh.
Do we sell this or keep?
Sell?
Sell.
Okay.
Oh no it's him.
Oh no please.
Please.
There's no way that I was gonna say I'm so fucking strong
now.
There's no fucking way
We're gonna grab more super chat
Oh my god, what is my screen?
Let's go back and just grab everything on this Oh my they
can't even walk anymore I fucked them up.
Oh, there's this knockback.
It's so confusing.
I don't know what's a character and what's an attack
anymore.
It's like such a blur.
I feel like I can, I think I can like actually stand still.
I'm pretty sure I can actually just stand still and not have
to worry about it.
Yeah, I'm at that stage.
I'm definitely at that stage.
all right uh all right headphones yeah oh no never mind i
can't i can't keep okay i can't i can kill them that's right
i have all the powers i have every perm except for nintendo
because i'm a serial nintendo but all right uh lava okay
we're gonna grab do we get bomb or no do we should do that
give in to that dude steve thank you for the super chat
thank you thank you thank you thank you thank you i'm gonna
get super chat one fear nintendo all right yeah the one
company you do not want to piss off they have they have like
so much power they don't like like because there it's like
one of those is like a company that's more so of like they
know they have so much good publicity that like bad
publicity doesn't hurt them because they hold they they hold
so much good publicity at that point that like they can just
release a new Zelda game and people will just forget like no
it's true you can be like wow Nintendo why would you do that
and then the moment they announce a new Zelda game everybody
will forget all the bad shit
they booed her because she's right
sadly true we said I keep this
than shrink.
Swap?
Okay.
Do we swap or sell?
Sell.
Okay, I'm gonna sell.
You can't fool her because she's right.
It's true.
It's so true.
No, no, she's coming.
Oh, no.
It's Toho.
No, not Toho!
I can't do Toho!
Like it's so bad because I can't I actually can't see I
can't see my attacks Oh my god I can't see
It's bad because I don't know I don't know where which was
her attack and which one is mine
So it's fine Oh god Oh I did it I knew it We did it Holy
fuck Okay I knew it I know you couldn't Fucking disappoint
me Holy shit Nice we did it Oh We did it guys Oh my god Oh
my god.
Let's go to Moome's house.
Let's go.
Hello Moome.
What is this?
Oh my god, they're all here.
We're doing.
This is my fucking village.
Do I have enough money?
Where's my fishing?
Okay, fishing.
Beginner's rod.
Dad's rod.
Golden rod.
Okay, how do I sell?
Exchange.
Talk.
Welcome to the fish shop.
i'm i'm bloop and i trade in fishing goods okay how do i
fish hello
oh guys i guys i don't i don't have the right keyboard i i
don't have arrow keys like i don't have arrow keys okay now
we're good.
Now we're good.
Okay, here we go.
Boom.
Wait, what?
Is this not arrow keys?
How?
I'm using the arrow keys.
It's WSD?
Okay, it's WSD.
How the fuck is I see arrow key?
I see arrow key.
How the to know like my brain goes like oh hey arrow key oh
shit i got tuna are these real people are you real people
can i have more stuff
hello are you real no oh that would be great if they were
real i was gonna say like give me all your fish if you're
real Oh my god.
The real game.
What do I do?
Can I sell my fish?
I guess I sell my fish for stuff, right?
So the more fish I have...
They're at the...
They're ChatGPT.
Okay.
They're also...
Why can't I not recruit my fans?
The fish for me!
I can't believe it.
This is fucked up.
I can't, like, I can't have my fans fish for me, so I can...
Oh, I can cook!
I can make tempura!
Increased attack by...
What do I need attack for?
Is it for, like, just this run?
What is this?
Manage, hire, send out an advertisement to get recruits.
Do I...
Can I...
Oh!
Can I collect my fans here?
hello
why do i need oh thank you okay why do i need a cook okay
i'll make one tempura i don't have enough money for tempura
oh how do i how do i like okay let's see bye what in bed is
there a way to like, how do I collect my fan, like, collect
fans?
How do I steal other people's fans?
I think that's, like, the better question.
Just lead me to my pen, I guess.
Hire.
Oh, I have to hire people.
Okay.
I can't believe I have to pay the money?
see.
We'll grab it.
What can I make you do?
Tomato.
Alright.
Status.
We like curling once.
I don't have tomatoes!
There, you're all burdened out.
I mean, it's the closest to it.
It's the closest to a dragon.
I can't believe it's a tomato, too.
Alright.
What do you do?
Collection?
Give me your money.
Give me your fucking money, Dragoon.
Nice.
That's fucking right.
Earn me the money!
My lunch money.
Alright, we got a fucking plant a tomato, apparently.
Put me in, boss.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Kato, thank you for the super chat.
but you might have to read no never you'll never get me to
read all right wait what about my fucking i don't have
standard soil okay standard so okay i'm gonna get enhanced
soil i have the money for this okay just a plant a tomato
there you go i have to feed my dragon somehow that's right
That's fucking right, Grant Gimm.
That's fucking right.
Earn your keep.
Hello.
Alright, I should buy, like, something.
Let me buy...
Uh...
We'll buy a...
We'll just buy a...
We'll buy Gamer Chair.
We'll buy...
Okay, we're Yellow Gamer Chair.
What the fuck?
It's $75,000?
Bro, this gamer chair better fucking fix my back.
My back's okay, but I better never have back problems in my
life after that.
Like, what the fuck?
If I have to water my tomato, just die.
75,000.
Bro, okay.
I can't believe it.
I'm gonna sleep on the fucking floor.
Like, why the fuck?
What the fuck is the...
Bro!
And the nice...
I'm fucking buying this zero dollars.
Bro.
This is way too fucking expensive, man.
Bro, we're gonna sleep on the fucking couch.
Apparently...
What the fuck?
What are these guys doing there?
Kiera, are you okay, Kiera?
Alright.
Okay, inventory.
Apparently...
Wait, build mode.
How do I fucking put my stuff here?
Okay.
Bed.
There you go.
That's it.
That's all I need.
Oh wait, I can- wait, can I put a shrimp?
No.
This is all I need.
There you go.
Nice.
I can't.
I'm stuck.
Did I just find a bug?
Of course, of course.
If it's anybody, it's me.
Okay, here we go.
There we go.
Of course.
Only I can find bugs.
Alright.
So when you place it on top of a person, you get stuck.
You get stuck.
Who would have thought?
What the fuck?
I don't know.
What are you doing here?
Do I have a pet army too?
What are you doing there?
Oh my god, you're earning your money.
already saw what's behind the house this is a bunch of these
guys these fuckers over here yeah later yeah what are you
guys doing huh yeah what the fuck are you guys doing over
there huh she's keeping them in line feed us I don't have
food oh my god at the water let's chill you'll get your
fucking food soon.
Or you can starve.
I don't know.
Alright.
You know what?
Oh, oh my god.
I can talk about my Zachidon.
Oh my god.
Anyway, as I was saying, for Hollow Fest shit.
That shit was so funny.
Because like, I don't know, me.
I'm pretty sure like some of them must.
Like you have to do like dams classes and stuff.
Like I remember I had to I did like personal dance classes
and everything too.
And like, oh my God, it's so much work.
So like, I know how like it's like that plus 10 fold because
they're doing a concert too.
Like, oh my God.
I would like, for me, I remember like I did dance classes
every other day.
And I had like the hardest fucking choreo.
I chose the hardest fucking choreo too.
Because I was like, I really want to dance really well.
remember like oh my god like seeing that i'm like oh god
they must have fucking did so much fucking work for that
shit like like the flips and everything i'm like jesus
that's so tiring that's so fucking tiring and i like i paid
for those personal dance classes for myself like oh tomato
give me a sec i gotta give you guys some uh it's super
intense and i like paid for my own personal dance classes
too so like because i wanted to dance really really well and
then um i remember just doing like a month straight of just
non-stop dance classes every other day oh my god it rains
there's weather okay we're gonna can i feed you guys how do
i feed you feed oh shit oh you can level up oh that's cool
I'm gonna level you Now you want potato?
Alright, I'm firing you now You're getting fired now How
dare you I can't believe it You can ditch your You can ditch
like that How fucking dare you How could you Look at me How
could you I can't believe you wanted potatoes
I'm so fucking weird Please I have a family Yeah And your
family decided you want to eat potatoes You're not a real
goon You're not You're not a real dragon
Oh shit free fish Free fish There's no balanced diet.
It's just tomatoes.
This is a tomato family.
Dragoon.
This is literally a tomato family.
How dare you?
Straight from the family heritage.
Alright.
Anyway.
I think this is a good time to call.
I had a lot of fun.
Honestly, like the hours passed by is so fucking fast.
um it actually has been like incredibly fun playing holo
cure i never uh uh i didn't think i'd be like i just i knew
it was like super addicting but like oh my god i didn't
realize how addicting this game is and i honestly had an
incredible time playing it and uh oh i'm gonna call it here
guys thank you guys so much for watching everybody as always
everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing have you so for me head to bed
because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time everybody
bye guys bye